hey oh
ladies and gentlemen welcome to fat man
beyond I'm Kevin Smith I'm Mark Bernardi
hey
as bam fan told you before the show got
started kids at home uh we are doing
this uh live streaming from the first
time uh from smodcast Castle Cinemas in
Atlantic Highlands New Jersey this is
the movie theater that I grew up going
to when I was a kid and whatnot I've
told the story before to people who were
here live but the home audience probably
doesn't know this this is the theater
where I saw the Friday the 13th that had
the heavyset kid in it and it was packed
like this opening Friday night it was a
Friday and fourth Friday the 13th Place
was [__] packed with peers and
teenagers and Ed hapstack's mod bless
him uh my friend at one point when uh
the heavyset dude was eating chocolate
and [__] Dead Silence in the audience he
goes there's Kev Smith
um so this theater traumatized me at a
young age tonight we're about to erase
all of that and partly uh the reason
that's going to be a race is because I
get to sit here with the great Mark
Bernard and give it up for Mark
foreign
[Applause]
how are you my friend uh I'm ecstatic
yeah I'm electric I'm thrilled I'm not
sleepy at all let's [__] do a podcast
man uh first off for those in the room
and for those at home Happy St Patrick's
Day everybody
I tried to wear a green jacket but the
green jacket I got from was from before
I lost a bunch of weight and so it I
looked like David Byrne in the in the
jacket so instead I'm going with the
untraditional blue
um we have just concluded uh The Ides of
Mark which is a mini Film Festival that
we had here uh starting on on the 15th
the odds of March uh it ran from
Wednesday Thursday and then it ended
tonight on on Wednesday we watched Dune
David Lynch's Dune the best Dune yes the
masterful dude uh them yes last night we
watched Streets of Fire
with about 20 people and and it was
amazing like because a lot of those cats
hadn't even seen who was here put your
hands together last night thank you
some cats had never seen it before man
so it was kind of a revelation uh
tonight at five o'clock we watched uh
Flash Gordon and we had a lot more
people here for that
um the festival went incredibly well uh
we're gonna do it again next year uh it
stemmed from a joke that was told like
on the show I think yeah like at one
point I was like I got a movie theater
you should do something there it was
like let's do the odds of Mark and I was
like that's hysterical and it literally
turned into a [__] thing so be
careful what you say out loud around me
I'll be like that's marketable
and apparently last night when we were
doing uh Streets of Fire I I pitched you
another one kind of on the Fly uh keep
calm and Curry on three Tim Curry movies
because we were talking about Legend
yeah we're like let's just do a bunch of
Tim Curry movies so and so I was like oh
we could do Legends we were talking
about Legend and then Mark was like we
could do clue
yes and then Mark was desperate to avoid
The Rocky Horror Picture Show but I
don't know how you do keep calm and
Curry on without doing it so we might
have to do that but I always feel weird
trying to do which one
Times Square
Three Musketeers that's right he's in
that as well
home alone too
could you imagine
um whatever the third the wild card spot
will be perhaps we'll leave it open to
the public the Legend's the first one
what hey
hey interactive [__] show
I said we'll vote online people uh but
yeah so we'll do keep calm and carry on
man maybe we'll do like you know because
we can't wait all the way until the next
march because that would be the odds
Mark so maybe March April May June July
August so September September keep calm
and carry on so that every six months
I'm coming out yeah sweet
um nice
um we've got so much a show for you uh
tonight lots of things that we didn't
cover in the last in the home show that
we did
um so how do you want to kick off
um well we've both seen some stuff yes
right today I saw Shazam Fury of the
Gods oh [__] did you I did did you see
it for free here no
[Laughter]
smart Castle Cinemas where even Mark
Bernardin won't come
for free uh no because you were playing
a little too late in the day yeah so I
needed I needed a matinee so I went at
uh 12 40 over in Hazlet
um the [__] Cinemark yeah
if you had a matinee out of company
fair enough uh to be we talked about it
with the uh the audience before we ran
the show but for the folks watching at
home this is also a first run movie
theater so like real ass movies are
playing here not just like 80s movies
like we've been doing all week so the
atom driver shoots Dinosaurs movie is
here
uh Creed 19 is here
um and Shazam opened here uh tonight so
I guess our first show is like four
o'clock or something like that uh the
seven o'clock show earned how many
people bought tickets for the night show
I think that was the four o'clock how
many people bought tickets for the night
show somebody go ask Connor up front
this is one of my favorite games to play
is be like how many people bought
tickets like when we did Dune the other
night like Dune was the highest grossing
film it's mod Castle Cinemas on
Wednesday night because like 65 had one
person in it one person was like I love
Adam Driver and I love dinosaurs and I'm
willing to do this [__] alone
kylo renades dinosaurs take my money
um when we opened Creed here uh I think
Creed had six people on opening night uh
when we opened Avatar Avatar had 12
people on opening night a lot of people
like yeah that's because you don't do 3D
and I'm like but we are like one of the
only movie theaters in a 10 mile radius
and [__] but whenever we do something
old the place fills up like a couple
last week I guess we was when we did
clerks open all night where we showed uh
clerks clerks two and clerks three from
midnight till seven in the morning
people came in their pajamas and stuff
um and and oddly enough didn't sleep
through the whole thing
um even me I was awake I was like what's
going to happen to this Dante no I hope
he lives
um but uh older stuff really tends to
play here I mean I guess it's because
there are other movie theaters in the
area like the aforementioned Cinemark
um our [__] Lex Luthor
um but uh yeah old stuff I think the
further we go on the more we'll find
luck with the older stuff we showed the
Muppet movie here as part of a series of
films called uh the movies that made me
and I wasn't here for it sadly but um we
had like 160 people for the Muppet movie
so much so that Ernie was like these
Muppets they're a thing aren't they
and so he got like you know we had there
was no kids movie out like two weeks ago
so Ernie just ordered up a muppet Muppet
movie we tried to get
um the great Muppet Caper but I guess we
got Muppets Take Manhattan or something
like that and ran that for a week and
actually had more people come to that
than come to 65. I mean I'm not like
bashing on 65. it's just when you think
about like owning a movie theater you're
like I'm Gonna Be Rich that is not the
case
unless you're showing older [__] uh but
the case in point mark went and saw a
new thing down the road let's talk about
Shazam I'm not going to say much because
it literally opened today so I'm not
going to spoil anything but I will say I
think if anybody knows me
I was not going and expecting very much
bar was low the bar was incredibly low I
I I might have been expecting more from
Ant-Man than I was from from Shazam oh
[__] we saw how that went I know
um Mark's still talking bitterly about
Ant-Man
the gangbang of it I was talking about
my [__] relatives
um I was talking about my relatives I
was literally talking about my aunt he
was like I had nothing to do with
quantumania and he was like Aunt man
um but I surprisingly did not hate
Shazam put that on a poster right there
surprisingly didn't mean Beyond
um tell us what did you not hate about
it you know it uh it's it's a kids movie
and so you can't expect much in terms of
Stakes really you can't expect much in
terms of of real gravity but by the end
of that movie it kind of gets
surprisingly emotional in ways that I
didn't expect you know and much of it is
because you know where Billy Batson is
in terms of his adolescence where he is
in relation to his family you know and
and him sort of moving from one phase of
life to another and I did find myself
kind of moved in the last Act of it I
was not really moved in the first two
acts because whatever
um and like all they have to do is
finish well though
movies in general like as long as you
leave the theater happy then it doesn't
matter if the first two acts kind of sag
or sucks yeah like I don't understand
why Judy Dench is in that movie like I'm
sorry Helen mirror not Judy Dench Helen
mirror but still good point yeah I
didn't understand why Judy dentures in
either because she's not in the [__]
movie yeah just walking around the
background like just looking for stuff
she was dressed as a cat with no [__]
um Helen Mirren the great Helen Mirren
um who's married to a director Taylor
Hackley yeah who directed Ray yeah
amongst other things I always think of
him as a director of Against All Odds ah
deep cut yeah very deep cut something
we'll be showing here next week as a
first Run movie
um but like listen I've I've had worse
times than superhero movies again for
the poster
um
but you could do worse then go see
Shazam if you're the Gods like go see
quantumania was there a last the last
Shazam was surprised the first Shazam I
should say was a surprisingly uh
touching film by the end when they
brought the family together and all his
fellow orphan spoilers became like the
Marvel family
um was it did it function kind of like
that
um a little bit a little bit I mean
I I hesitate very much to spoil a lot I
will say that there was a cameo in that
movie that I had heard got cut but
wasn't
Wonder Woman
I mean he they spoiled it like they they
marketed that for the last like three
days online the internet was so mad
because like why does DC keep giving
away like the way Black Adam was like
Hey man Superman's in the movie and [__]
and then they started doing that for
this as well so I knew that Wonder Woman
was in it from the from three days ago I
didn't say it right like I was trying to
be [__] cool about this and
spoilers yeah
where in the movie beginning middle and
end very end yeah like post-credits
scene or like in the movie in the movie
proper and was she like congratulations
you're a superhero or something like
that
yes welcome to the Justice League is
that what she does no oh because I was
like [__] this show I'm gonna go see
that right now
um here's the thing I bet you like after
this is done uh for the people in the
theater here uh we're gonna be watching
a little something a little something uh
that we're not good yes
are we allowed to decide
I mean guys I haven't been that [__]
precious about it online but you know
it's just a bonus like if you came all
the way from wherever you came you know
the very least is we can not just give
you a show for one two three hours
probably not three
um oh it might be three
yeah like what have we ever done hey
it's a tight 45 everybody go home yes
um but yeah just a little something like
a little [__] gift basket in the verb
version of a movie we're going to show
you for 15 minutes and 16 seconds is
that how long it is yes 15 16 15 16. uh
for those at home going what are they
talking about uh Mark has talked about
on the podcast many times and we've
updated throughout the episodes uh he
said by the time he was 50 he wanted to
direct something and he did he directed
a short called Splinter so when we're
done with fat man beyond once we're
offline uh we're gonna actually since we
know a guy with a movie theater we're
actually gonna show the short to
everybody here in attendance and whatnot
um
[Applause]
incredibly sympathetic to because we had
some almost 3 000 donors to this movie
and many of them have not gotten to see
it yet
um all they have to do is come to
smartcastle cinema apparently uh some of
you are in the house and for that I
remain eternally grateful but for the
ones who are not in the house and
couldn't be a part of it and I'm like
why are you [__] showing that movie
and I can't see it yet technically
the festival yeah I can show it at
Festival ah look at it look at your work
around very nice loopholes are your
friend I can't distribute it and
technically sending it out to 3 000
people would count as digital
distribution so I can't do that right
but just between us girls we can watch a
movie right yeah
you wouldn't hear the filmmaker you
could do whatever you want including
make yoga hosers
um for uh for those in the audience how
many people uh helped what did you do
Kickstarter or yes Kickstarter how many
people helped Kickstart it put your
hands together
look at that
you made his dream come true and you're
gonna see the results tonight uh maybe
after that's over we'll watch the last
three minutes of Shazam
just skip the rest of the movie huh
that's how it ends all right
um how was the the Cinemark Theater what
do they do that we don't that you went
there well they showed them matinees
uh it's it's I have some Nostalgia for
that theater because for a long time
that was the theater when I lived in New
Jersey I lived in Aberdeen New Jersey
for like 15 years and that was my movie
theater and Mark's lady comes from the
area as well yeah she was born in
Middletown and lived in Red Bank when I
met her
um and we when we bought a house and got
married and had children that happened
in Aberdeen so that was my sort of
little Hometown pocket so going back in
there was like oh that dumb arcade is
still in the quarter that still has
[__] like a Terminator salvation
video game salvation yeah
that's the one that's the one with uh
Sam Worthington yeah and and the
Christian yeah Christian Bell the scream
when he got Batman yes in that movie was
a but on the set of that movie that's
the one where he's like oh good for you
out of my [__] sight line which he
apologized for he went on like Ralph
Garmin on Hollywood Babylon always does
his impression of of uh Christian Bale
screaming and stuff but uh Ralph worked
at K-Rock for years uh on the Kevin and
Bean show and Christian Bale like they
were making fun of him for like all all
day for that and then Christian Bale
called in and actually was like look I
just want to apologize I'm not going to
try to do this British accent
I'm so sorry
um
I'm so sorry I'll do is Batman that's
better
but apologize and talk to him for a
while and Ralph was just like for a
while they were vetting the call going
this can't be him but it was legit him
man so I always thought that was kind of
classy move uh not what he yelled at
somebody but like when he was like yeah
that was a dick move and stuff
um what else was the experience like
it's in the market that was the popcorn
uh didn't have any my seats were a
little [__] up oh really do tell uh
because they got like the fancy Dancy
reclining seats yeah yeah but there was
a sign above every theater saying if you
have an issue with your seat let us know
before the movie starts so I'm gonna sit
down in my seat and the one next to me
looks like it had been like it's a it's
like Dom Toretto had driven it off a
cliff and it landed somewhere and so the
seat was [__] out and sideways
hashtag family and uh and so that
because that's he was [__] up my seat
didn't move and I was like oh well
luckily there's only four other people
in this giant theater imma just pick
another seat nice and I did that was my
experience [__] up seat okay movie no
popcorn uh that's the one thing we get a
lot of credit for here here in the house
one uh at uh smart Castle Cinemas uh the
biggest complaint is about the seats uh
the people like these seats aren't
[__] nice or comfortable or good at
all
um
but these are the seats that like like
these were the seats when I used to come
here as a kid so I have a real hard time
kind of letting it go uh we have had
like the option to pick up seats from
other closing movie theaters I should
have known when other movie theaters are
closing I should have been like perhaps
now's not the time to buy a movie
theater mercifully I bought it with a
bunch of friends so we all kind of share
the wealth and the burden and stuff but
we've talked about
um replacing the seats in some of the
other theaters but this one I feel like
I gotta keep these seats man like I
would hate to you know number one if you
bring in those company layback seats we
would lose number I think we have about
230 possible seats here but there's
something wonderfully nostalgic for me
and I'm sure people sitting in the seats
like it's not nostalgic for my ass
[__] but
but having these seats makes all the
difference here um there's another
theater that we got that has really
[__] nice seats man not like the
layback seats but they're they look like
seats like when you play those arcade
games and you're driving a car and [__]
like that they look like those seats and
they're very low to the floor that's why
I watched where I watched Avatar and the
seat was incredibly low to the floor
these are you know kind of standard ass
seats from the 70s and 80s I'll be
honest with you maybe even the 60s at
this point yeah these seats were giving
me flashbacks because when I went to uh
I did a marathon it did a Marvel movie
marathon where I saw theater this was at
the El Capitan worst [__] seats on
the planet yeah yeah and I was in that
theater for 36 hours
it was from Iron Man to Infinity war and
they pretty much showed I think they
skipped one or two movies it was 18
movies
uh did they skipped Thor too yes
mercifully yeah and Ant-Man 2 who gives
a [__] but uh they skipped Iron Man Too
Ant-Man too Ant-Man they made us watch
Iron Man
because it's that [__] bird
um but like I just remember the pain of
trying to sleep in those seats and
trying to find a way to be comfortable
and also the vapor trails of odors from
dudes dressed as Thor and encased in
Hulk plastic [__] fake armor I
imagine the first show you're like yeah
I'm dressed as Thor in four movies in
you're like why did I dress like Thor
yeah and it was like catered by
Chick-fil-A
and so uh like a 24-hour Chick-fil-A
burn in a bunch of people in a theater
who not leaving like bro
tough that smell was high
we have talked about uh trying to do
that here but like that's uh Disney puts
out all the Marvel movies and Disney is
like really kind of
stingy when you want to do a stingy they
just don't let us do
um older movies and stuff like we showed
I mean I don't know if I should admit
this but we showed Iron Man at one point
um and so far they haven't sued us but
uh they were very like you can't do that
it was a guy Warner Brothers recently
did that when we showed Batman a few
months ago and then we wanted to show
Batman Returns and Warner Brothers was
like absolutely not I think they're just
holding all Michael Keaton Batman until
June when the flash opens up but they
were like you can show mask of the
Phantasm and I was like oh I know two
dudes who were in that [__] so we showed
it and it was a wonderful screening here
but we've talked about like since we did
clerks open all night and showed three
clerks movies doing our version of that
Marvel like every movie marathon by
doing like a views Universe Marathon
which would be clerks Mall Rats Chasing
Amy Dogma Jane Silent Bob Strike Back
um clerks to
Jay and Silent Bob reboot and then
clerks three eight movies but I don't
know if like if it's such a weird roller
coaster you know because like clerks yay
Mal rats yay chasing him he deeply
[__] emotional
um Dogma it makes you question your
[__] Faith Jay and Son Bob Strike
Back brings your faith back to you
um but would you suggest doing it over
the course of one day or two days if we
would do something like that as a man
who sat through many it's a man who did
it how what's what do you think the
running time is all in like 12 13 hours
eight movies at like six let's average
I was going to say an hour 45 but who
can do that [__] mail let's just say
two hours a piece even though most of
them are 90 minutes
so like let's call it 14 hours
um if you start on a Saturday at like 6
p.m you can probably get to Dogma at
Sunday at 1201 to go to church that's
true it'd be like going to mass you can
skip church that day
I think I think you just you do them all
you do them all from you just pick a
starting time 6 PM's not so bad like
you're kind of so you can endure the
emotional heartache of Chasing Amy while
you're still awake yes you know and you
get Dogma at midnight you sort of
[__] ride that high and then you can
kind of end it at breakfast the next day
I believe we're doing I just spoke to
Jason Lee Jason Lee came out like a
month and a half ago we did Mall Rats
here with Jason Lee and Jeremy London
and Jason fell in love with the theater
he was like oh my God I [__] love
this and the idea of like people filling
up and coming to see him in Q a and
stuff
so he was like um let's do it again so
chasing Amy's anniversary is always in
April that's like when it came out so
we're talking about April 21st doing a
Chasing Amy screening here uh with Jason
Lee in the very near future we're doing
March 31st I think it is
um Brian Quinn is bringing the
Impractical Jokers movie here and we'll
do a q a after that I think April 1st
we're doing Bob Hawks documentary film
Hawk and then I forget what we're doing
on the second uh April 20th 4 20 of
course I believe we're doing strike back
and reboot as a double feature
um you know bring your own weed and um
and then uh the Chasing Amy thing would
happen on like the Sunday after the
Saturday after that
um so you can we'll let you know when
that's going to happen
um God what was the thing I wanted to
bring up Vamp for a second I forgot
hello my baby hello my darling hello my
ragtime gal
pretty [__] good man right just like
that frog
Michigan J frog
the marathon
yeah I was done but there was something
else I wanted to talk about now I
totally skipped my mind what's that the
liquor license I mean we could talk
about that
um we're getting a liquor license and
we're done
um yeah I think it'd be much easier to
sit through eight vsq movies if you were
drunk
uh but most theaters that like when I
went on the convenience tour uh from
September to December a lot of them were
uh mom and pop own they weren't like
part of Cinemark your best [__]
friends and [__]
um and the two things they said were
like because I was like I bought a movie
theater they're like I'm so sorry
and I was like why and they're like
you're never gonna make money off the
movies and I was like well you know I
know you make money off concessions and
they're like you ain't gonna make money
off popcorn you're the only way to stay
in business is to have a liquor license
number one and number two this is this
is a suggestion from the folks at the
Rio theater in Vancouver they're like if
you want to stay alive you got to start
serving grilled cheese sandwiches
and I was like really and they're like
oh my god get two Panini presses and
offer grilled cheese it is [__] up how
much people love cheese
I was like is that a Canada thing like
that is worldwide man so we have on our
menu board like grilled cheese but we've
never done it yet
so I think we gotta add a sticker coming
soon uh but yes liquor license will be
next we're taking out like we've got
five screens it's spawn Castle Cinemas
so we're gonna take out one of the
screens and turn that into a bar a bar
themed like a movie theater
um so uh that that'll be a few months
before it happens but oh my god when
that happens like you charge like ten
dollars for a drink that costs like 75
cents and [__] then I'll be rich Mark
yes so you're all seeing are we gonna
take advantage of you once again yes
like you guys
I'm gonna charge you 500 more than this
cost me
and you'll love me for it the uh the
movies that we did this weekend or this
week for the Ides of Mark
um you can't just show them right you
got to pay for them and stuff and so uh
flat Streets of Fire Estonia I was like
how much is Streets of Fire it's like
200 bucks and uh I was like all right so
we charge 20 bucks a ticket and [__] so
at 10 seats we were already like paid
for the print and stuff like that
um but it's not just one flat fee like
if we had sold out the theater then it's
35 of whatever you make oh yeah so
what's in your best interest to not sell
out yes isn't that weird so I should not
have been flacking the internet so hard
to get people to show up you know
because it's actually less good for you
yes but for in terms of showing flicks
but in terms of doing this like we get
to keep all this money we don't have to
give anything to [__] Universal so
underachieve for the movies overachieve
you're a fat man for the live stuff
thank you the idea here is to like like
give people and experience right make it
experiential like you can go see a movie
anywhere you can go see Shazam at
Cinemark you don't have to come here for
it as we [__] heard nice commercial
man [__]
but like what you can do at other
theaters is like this or q a and like
before Ernie was talking about you know
I was joking like why did we buy a movie
theater and he was like because you'd
like to talk and it's true it is like
having your own kind of private personal
stage where you can do not just fun
movie things but then live podcasts as
well so we've been talking about doing
this for a red hot minute and y'all
showing up means the absolute world so
thank you for being here tonight kids
um I am uh [__] exhausted I got up at
three in the morning and uh couldn't
fall back asleep so I worked on a Green
Hornet me and Mark are working on a
Green Hornet cartoon series for the
folks of wild brain and um
slip is that the Green Hornet thing does
it is that swept no no that's the spider
Hornet
um it is the the animation isn't like
flat 2D animation it's that Pixar
looking [__] so they did a piece of
animation for us like a long time ago
when we were pitching the series which
is essentially the opening credits and
the idea was we were like let's do a
sequence like you know the opening of
Batman the Animated Series that just a
little vignette about the hero in action
and so when they put it together it's
like spellbindingly [__] good and
then we were like [__] now we gotta
write a good show and uh mercifully uh
Mark agreed to work on it and then uh
Han and Jenny are our other two writers
and so um at three in the morning when I
couldn't sleep I got up and worked on
episode what was it 107 was on script
like uh I've got the um uh what is my
title uh story editor story editor so
that means like you get to go over
everybody's work and stuff like that
um so they hand in a script and you get
to kind of add things to it or not as is
the case with the Han stuff is like so
incredibly well written but when I was
doing that at three in the morning I was
like as soon as I finished this I'll go
back to sleep but I did not [__] go
to sleep now because my dog shecky lives
upstairs as well with me and she's 18
years old and um if she's blind as [__]
man like she's got a great nose like
she'll find me anywhere in this place
and last night when we were doing the
show like uh Mark was doing Q a after uh
Streets of Fire and I had to like let my
dog out and stuff and I took the dog out
she went outside she always pisses right
in front of the movie theater doors I'm
like come on man
uh but then I brought her in and she's
just doing laps while we were doing Q a
and at one point somebody was like your
dog's taking a [__] and
she sure did she took a [__] in the
[__] aisle so she kept me up man she
wouldn't go to sleep and whatnot and so
uh this morning I went hiking in
Highlands is my hometown where I grew up
and did about four and a half miles I
got my 10 000 steps in before like 11
o'clock and then I realized like what a
stupid idea because I'm so [__] tired
right now so I'm glad that you're
electric because I might just [__]
fall asleep during the show if you see
me pass out kids it's solely for that
reason uh do we want to talk about some
other [__] that we've seen because we
can talk about uh Last of Us finale
let's begin with The Last of Us Bam um
oh hey
you know you know it's bamf man
everybody give it up for Banff man
I I'm gonna throw out there that the
um other way that you can make money at
a movie theater is by doing ads maybe we
do an ad before
we've we have uh
we have a old old friend returning
oh we actually have you're saying we
have to do in it we have to do an ad I'm
being not so subtle I forgot about that
I was so busy plugging my [__] I forgot
about somebody paying for us that's
right kids uh our uh the good Folks at
manscaped are our sponsors and I give it
up for the good Folks at manscape
that would have been that's why we
should have had a laptop I could have
had my [__] copy in front of me but
Mark's got the copy it's about the weed
wax here yeah yeah we'll [__] do it
first off if you're at home kids right
now and you're following along uh to get
20 off and free shipping just go to uh
where oh manscaped.com
and enter our code Fatman 20 Mass 20 off
with free shipping at manscaped.com use
our code fatman20 always use the right
tools for the job with manscaped uh this
week the manscaped folks sent a weed
whacker it's called 2.0 and I was like
oh [__] man this is for cutting ball
here and now because that's generally
what manscaped is all about yeah and
it's a little dangerous when somebody's
like weed whacker for your ball yes
it's not that's not a deep control
element on a weed whacker halfway
through using it because before you can
endorse it you're like let me see if
this works
um I was using on my ball hair and then
I looked at the box and it's like for
ear and nose hair so
so I was like oh [__] and I used them in
the proper places and it [__] really
worked man I'm like yeah I got all the
hair out of my ears I'm starting to feel
like an old man and [__] I was seeing
come [__] pop out and whatnot like a
grandpa uh and went up my nostrils as
well and it didn't cut me or anything
like it cut what it was supposed to nice
which I guess is like the best
endorsement you can give it tore up your
balls but it left your ears don't use
the weed whacker on your nuts but that
being said you've used the Shavers on
your head not the weed whacker but the
other correct I have indeed used both
the beard shaver on my beard and then
I've used the regular thing on my head
especially during the pandemic when I
wasn't letting like strange people near
my head
um I was I was a do-it-yourself Bob I
was a DIY [__] Barber guy do it
yourself yeah cutting your own [__] and
making my own Rhymes how often do you
work on your nut hair
well uh it all depends on the day what
my plans are for the night you know but
a little [__] quaff grease on that
[__]
Snidely Whiplash it and then head out
for another town
um I'm going to read some of their
coffee because generally they always
write good copy huge dramatic sounds
this is a public service announcement
manscaped now has beard products and is
going even further with their brand new
weed whacker 2.0 go ahead and tell the
world uh the leaders uh in below the
waist grooming are traveling north of
your South Pole that's pretty good wow
it's like Christmas theme yeah very much
so uh north of your South Pole with the
Revolutionary grooming products the new
weed wacker 2.0 and their new beard line
uh confirms they have all the best tools
for your hygiene toolbox time for you to
upgrade your game by going to
manscaped.com and using our code Fatman
20 for 20 off plus free shipping so
since we've got like 200 people here
jump on your phones we'll wait go buy
one okay uh if you're at home kids uh
don't forget the good Folks at manscape
sponsoring uh the show tonight always
been a wonderful sponsor for us and
stuff and always send free products I
have so many [__] Shavers I have more
Shavers than I'll ever be able to use in
a lifetime because they always send me
one and I'm like I have this already but
I don't want to complain because free is
pretty yeah totally look for us to
auction those off at the next Batman
Beyond uh Folks at home don't know but
like before the show began
we I always like to do one of my
favorite [__] things in the world is
to sell [__]
um because I used to be a guy who sold
[__] for other people and whatnot work
in a quick stop which is the convenience
store from clerks which is not very far
from here at all it's about a mile and a
half down the road in Leonardo
um so I'm a I'm an old school [__]
nickel and dime guy
um and before the screenings like since
we don't make a lot of money in the film
exhibition business like I always like
to bring [__] up and sell off
one-of-a-kind uh what not so before we
went right before we went I was like
selling [__] like [__] for cash and
credit cards and stuff and then we
started the show so sooner or later I
will start selling some manscape gear
uh right off the stage man but until
then we thank the good Folks at
manscaped for being sponsors give it up
for the good Folks at manscape
um is that good enough bamf man can we
move on
bam sounds good to me
there it is covers our obligations
there it is uh that's what's important
yes
um all right I have not watched a single
episode of uh the last of us yet but I
know it's done now so I can watch the
whole [__] thing you absolutely can
has anybody else watched
are we all caught up does everybody seen
everything
now this show has become insanely
popular for HBO it has indeed I think
the finale pulls something like eight
and a half million viewers oh my God and
this is one of 186 shows that Pedro
Pascal is on is that correct yes it's
it's the one in which he's actually on
the set yes
I was watching the Mandalorian today
going like I know that's not him
have actually started putting his
doubles in the credits yeah because have
they really yeah Brendan Wayne who was
John Wayne's grandson he's the
Mandalorian he's one of the mandalorians
he's like the walking around Mandalorian
and then there's a fighting Mandalorian
and then there's like the one time that
dude's got to take over his mask
Mandalorian and that's Pedro Pascal and
I guess there's a long tradition of that
in Star Wars and as much as like David
prowse was Darth Vader but he certainly
didn't sound like David prowse yeah you
can watch that like section on there's a
little clip online of Darth Vader from
Star Wars but with David prowse's voice
and he's like come here princess
if this is a console [__] where are the
ambassadors uh it was a good move
getting uh James Earl Jones but uh I I
did as I was watching Mandalorian today
I was like man what a dream gig it must
be for Pedro Pascal you just walk into a
Sound Studio and you're just like this
is the way thank you
meanwhile it's John Wayne's grandson
yeah running around doing [__] check him
out yeah um all right so let's talk
about Last of Us where Pedro actually
does show up all the time he actually
does show up all the time um you were a
big fan of the game I was a huge fan of
the game did anybody else play the game
um the the TV show in the game have been
very kind of in lockstep with the events
that happen with a couple of diversions
there's the Franken Bill episode which
is phenomenal if you've never seen it
with with uh with uh no Noah John
Offerman and Nick Offerman why did I
[__] up that dude's name twice
uh Nick Offerman and uh Murray Bartlett
playing uh Frank and Bill who in the
game were just kind of like these Side
characters one of which you encounter on
Route defining some [__] the other one
is only kind of referred to but it
becomes this very heartbreaking
wonderful Standalone episode about just
two guys falling in love in the middle
of the end of the world
um so that for those of us that don't
watch the show it's about it's a it's
about uh it's about a zombie apocalypse
ultimately except in this show another
[__] show about that yes indeed but
in this show the zombies are not um it's
not a viral thing it's a fungal pandemic
basically they're like giant mushrooms
that want to eat people
are they the clickers in questions
that's what they call them clickers yes
the the technical term is cordyceps
which is the kind of fungal infection
that [__] with everybody so I mean
functionally it's a zombie show it's the
same thing but
um at least it's it's got a little
different spin on it
um and so it's basically it's it's a
Lone Wolf and Cub story it's you know
Joel Miller played by Pedro Pascal is a
guy who lost his daughter on the day the
[__] world ended and has been haunted
by that for the next 20 years of his
life and Ellie is a young woman who was
kind of brought up in the system who
happens to be spoilers uh immune to this
particular strain of zombie and why
spoilers they didn't reveal that until I
mean if you haven't seen the show I
don't want to tell you some [__] you
didn't want to know but they kind of
keep that a little bit of a secret
for uh for a beat in half it's like for
the first episode you kind of is he
immune as well nobody but her is
yeah
she that's why she's special right so
special and he's got a protector for
that he's got a protect her reason to
get her to a place to cure everybody
right to get her from one place
currently the Boston
um DMZ uh quarantine Zone all the way to
the fireflies which is this kind of
Rebel organization in the show who have
a hospital somewhere west of the Rockies
that might be able to synthesize a cure
for everybody if he can deliver her
there and you say everybody who's left
is there a large population left I mean
there's there's more people than you'd
think you know kind of clustered In
Pockets you know the big city still have
people there are there are places
there's a spot in Jackson Wyoming that
seems to be a thoroughly functioning
civilization where they have plumbing
and they have hot water and they have
food that they grow and not much of a
zombie problem at all like there's
places that you can go that it's not so
bad and they're big cities which is kind
of awful
um and so the game is very much a story
about Joel who wants nothing to do with
Ellie because she reminds him too much
of his dead daughter coming to
ultimately accept her as the surrogate
daughter that has now gone and she
begins to rely on him as the father who
she'd never had you know she's only ever
known people who would eventually leave
her or send her away and so there's this
lovely bond that forms between those two
characters over the course like 25 hours
of play in that game and there's action
[__] running and jumping and stabbing of
zombies and you know resource management
and all the stuff that happens in a game
like that but ultimately it's a story of
a broken man who learns to become a
father who then reluctantly becomes a
hero by the end of the game
and that's why I was so invested in the
show because I knew where it was going
right because the end of that game broke
me in like a dozen different ways and
the reason why is and we're all going to
talk about it here because we've all
seen it and now it's almost a week after
the finale and so
when Joel finally delivers Ellie to the
Firefly HQ they say okay we can we can
synthesize this cure from her from her
brain matter but we're gonna have to
kill her to do it oh [__] and so and you
do that from playing the game I knew
that from playing the game and the and
the way that
sort of unspools in the game is like
yeah he brings you there he's super
happy and then everything's great thanks
Joe you did the thing and then they tell
him that she's gonna die and then you as
the player are forced to rescue Ellie
because the hero in Joel should want to
save everybody right like that's the
thing the hero wants to save the most
people for the most reason tracks but
Joel is not a hero at that point Joel is
a dad and a dad is never going to choose
the good of the many they're only ever
going to choose the good of the one and
so Joel goes on this [__] hell bent
for leather Mission and like kills
everybody in this hospital to get to
where Ellie is being operated on and
then kills a Doctor Who's about to
operate her and then rescues her out of
it thereby dooming the rest of mankind
to this ongoing
and that was the end of the game the end
of the game and you can't not do it like
that you can't choose to be like you
know she'll be fine right I get it you
know it's fine there's plenty of little
girls out there I can take another
daughter I would just go all John
barenthal and be like you can't protect
a Rick and move on and [__] credits
um but so you have to you have no choice
what kind of [__] game is this uh
whatever the game is about choices and
[__] sometimes it is but like most games
at least most story based games are
about a story that the storytellers want
to tell and but what it does is makes
you complicit in that action it makes
you responsible for what you've done and
I've never really played a game that
made me feel that way and then it
becomes about does he tell Ellie what he
did what he did does he tell her that he
rescued her and then doomed the rest of
mankind to the world that she's the only
World she's ever known
and so he lies to her because that's a
thing you do in the game like XY live or
something like that at that point you're
watching a cut scene how much what is
the gameplay just shooting zombies
there's a lot of shooting of zombies or
shooting doctors as well
yeah there's some shooting of people
because there's a lot about like the the
other people alive during this this
hellscape are like just dudes who want
your [__] and so you're both trying to
survive and it's Walking Dead every
every zombie story is that way there's
the zombies and there's people who
survive the zombies and which one of
them is actually more sometimes they're
in the mall like Dawn of the Dead
sometimes they're in a mall
um and so the the game very much makes
you complicit uh TV show can't do that a
TV show can only portray a story for you
right so you're just watching Joel
become the Punisher by the end of this
thing which there's some joy to be taken
for sure but you lose the feeling that
you you lose the responsibility that you
had as a game player for that particular
part of the story and my my issue like I
liked the show I didn't love the show
and my only issue was that I it was Nine
episodes long and at least three of
those episodes are not about Joel and
Ellie it's not about welding these two
characters together so you understand
why Joe does what he does at the end we
spend an episode falling in love with
Frank and Bill only for them to die we
spent an episode falling in love with
Frank and Bill die yeah
of old age
spoiler oh of old age yeah like one dude
he's got a terminal condition but
there's no zombies that kill them it's
just he's getting sick and I love you
and so we're both gonna drink this
bottle of wine that has drugs in it
that's going to kill us and we'll have
one last great day
as husband and husband so they don't die
they commit suicide well that's also
dying though
[Laughter]
good point
but it's it's actually like sweet and
romantic and kind of gorgeous but
there's a couple of episodes that are
very Standalone and tell stories of
other people who have relationships
which are great episodes but it doesn't
do the thing of welding those two
characters together you know and so and
there's a another lovely episode called
Left Behind based on a downloadable
content chapter of the game that tells
of Ellie's first kiss of you know her
best friend and Ellie is gay in the
games and always has been and always
will be and so it's just it's in a mall
where these two characters just kind of
[__] flirt and hang out and have a
good time and and like right on a
[__] Carousel and play video games
until the zombie bites you know Ellie's
best friend and that's how Ellie
discovers that she is immune because her
friend is not and so they both get
bitten but only her friend turns and
like it's a lovely story but it doesn't
do the job of telling me why Joel is
going to kill everybody in a hospital to
save that girl and so that is my only
quibble with the show and that is my
only real quibble by the end of it is
that I just
I wanted to love them together and
instead I love them separately and
that's a choice that the show made and
it's it's executed very well but that
was just I felt a little Hollow at the
ends like oh well yeah hey dude it's a
lot which is weird because you'd imagine
like a drama TV drama would like pull
you in more than a a video game and yet
still you felt more emotional about the
game I did felt the same way about
Activision's Pitfall in the 80s you know
because it's once you got to like the
three crocodiles of the head you had to
jump on well when that scorpion popped
up [__]
um but yeah that was just that was my
takeaway like I I very much dug it I bet
you that show's gonna win like a handful
of Emmys
um but it it
it didn't it's like an A minus for me
like it's still very good but it didn't
it didn't Ascend to the same Heights
that the game did for me but I see where
they go for season two and probably
season three well that's my question it
sounds like the if they follow the game
closely like is there another game yes
so there's more than one game that's the
last part two is that right yeah yeah
and so that's what season two is going
to be see the last one is part it's an
easy job this isn't [__] why am I
bothering creating new [__] when I could
just get a video game be like let's just
follow this yeah just do what we did
yeah but a little different
um but I'm looking forward to it because
I like feeling bad about myself and so
like and those games are not [__]
like Good Time Charlie video games like
that right it is [__] Bleak
emotionally and physically
why do you make me hurt so much foreign
I love it when you make me hurt is this
the first video game
movie media TV show that's ever worked
based on a video game
um
I mean
listens it's [__] Super Mario
Brothers is going to be great
he said convincingly
um you know like the problem with most
of those things are is that they try to
replicate the game right which you can't
do
um I think like Resident Evil is
actually a pretty decent adaptation
because it then just becomes a horror
thing like what are you taking from the
game oh well it's [__] umbrella Corp
that created [__] zombies you know I
got this character who's got a kill book
of zombies that's cool we do nine of
these movies and they did
and you know they're all of varying
degrees of success I mean they're all
better than Street Fighter
um which is awful
but I mean something about Mortal Kombat
oh that's the thing it's like the rest
of the movie can suck because they have
the theme song
fatality
fittership Liu Kang wins my God you
could be the voice
tell them
the world give me that [__] cheddar
um but yeah like that was just that was
my takeaway like I appreciated it I it's
so [__] well done and so expertly
realized but it just got this a little
bit of emotional hollowness at the
center of it for me
um how did you guys feel did you like
did you dislike
loved
[Applause]
how many people hated The Last of Us
look at that that's pretty good that's
not bad no I mean that dude didn't
respond I think he just [__] hated
and won't say anything it's a guy ain't
saying [__] but man [__] those cut
scenes
uh you want to talk about Mando yeah
moving on man we'll talk about
Mandalorian how many people have been up
to date with the Mandalorian season
three
uh they've released three episodes so
far yes
um the first episode felt like a kind of
like Hey we're back and this is the
story and and I didn't feel like a lot
happened in it other than him going him
taking [__] for taking his helmet off
right and also him being like I need a
Droid that Droid the broken one yeah let
me fix it oh [__] it's trying to kill me
maybe I shouldn't have this Joy but I
need that Droid why do you need that
Droid for reasons okay I guess I gotta
go get parts for this Droid okay it's
basically like giving him the needs list
to go to space Radio Shack to buy parts
for the Droid they just gotta put back
together and then in episode two
completely abandoned
where he's just like I gotta get this
thing for an IG Droid we don't have it
nobody can get it how about
how about enjoy it in the quarter all
right
so we didn't need that at all no any
Droid will do it turns out is that was
that two or three three that was two
that's where he gets R5 D4 right who
they turn into like the at one point Amy
sidaris called calls him Frady Droid
Frady Droid and it all to like listen I
didn't like the first two episodes much
but you dig the first two episodes
because it was a like a list of [__]
that you had to do that he just
abandoned them in a different thing came
along and then he gets to Droid why do
we need the Droid we've got droid's got
to do readings for me when we get to
[__] Mandalore I was excited when he
was like we're bringing back IG 88 and
heard what is the name ig-11 yeah I
guess and he had the statue like
honoring him that was made of him yep
um and then when I was like oh [__] this
would be cool because I did like that
character it's one of the greatest
episodes of Mandalorian where he [__]
smokes everybody coming in and he's like
I'm a nurse
um but then it was I turned I didn't see
coming when he was still like he
reverted to his original programming
right
um but then when they get r5d4 to go and
do like [__] readings and [__] from
Mandalore R5 doesn't do that [__] no and
so [__] Mando's just like all right I
guess I'll seal my helmet and walk out
there myself so well you could have done
that the whole [__] time
like because he's going to man to the
actual Mandalore Planet because he wants
to bathe in the Living Waters of Lake
Minnetonka
precisely uh yeah and the witchy goes
and gets [__] like everybody's got a
safe Mando in episode two where it's
like I'm gonna walk down here and
[__] come with me you know grogu
it'll be fine and then he gets [__]
beset by the weird ass spider mechanized
Droid thing yeah go get help Lassie
which I thought was tell him I'm down
the well
um I thought it was cool I like the
design of that drug with the one human
eye inside and stuff the things that I
didn't like I was like man they went
cheap on that were the things that were
coming through the ceiling that we're
trying to eat the dragon things not the
baby dragon things the things that look
like people in Bad costumes oh right
like the Star Trek aliens from classic
very much so I thought they looked like
sleece Stacks from Land of the Lost and
[__] and I was like they must have run
out of money at that point it doesn't
look like any Star Wars thing normally
like you'll see background characters or
foreground characters that look like hey
that's boss okay that's this that's that
that one looked like a brand new
designer the [__] they ran out of money
bam yeah
I think it was uh a call back to the
time machine and the the future aliens
in the time machine
in a similar way in like book a Boba
Fett How They Carried uh called back to
uh the like forearmed Goro harryhausen
monster I think it was like a call back
to that early sci-fi time machine
um it seemed like a call back to a
cheaper era that's what it felt like
everything else especially because that
robot looks so [__] badass and [__]
so hey guys we got like nine spools of
carpet out back what should we do with
it I know let's make aliens yeah
um and I also like so the the plot of
the episode is we gotta go the [__]
minds of Mandalore we gotta go see
[__] Boca 10 Lounge in under Kick-Ass
throne
and then Mando's gonna do the thing
where he goes down there and gets caught
then grogu back gets back up gets bokeh
10 and she's gonna do the exact [__]
thing we're just watching like another
person play this level of this game
and like go down save Mando who's like
stuck in a [__] trap he did bust out
the darksaber which I thought was badass
he did and still get caught anything
yeah
not good at this and so then he's like
thank you Boca town for saving me let's
go find the waters and so they go down
to the waters he takes one [__] step
off the shelf and into the again the
well is too deep for Mando and so poker
says oh [__] I guess I gotta go save him
again is that what it was like he just
literally like went into the deep end or
wasn't he got pulled down or anything he
was like
Dives in yeah I thought that was cool as
[__] they showed like that outfit
underwater it's super cool but he's like
you know Virgil Brigman back on the air
because he went that [__] far down
and sees um yes
you and I both like enjoyed the [__] out
of that one dude likes the abyss too
um
right like all the bombings
what you can here at home is somebody in
the audience talking and uh say it again
so I can relate it to them it was Bo
Katan said what
because of the explosions that happen on
top back into normal
the floor that they walked on caved in
Thai bombers who [__] destroyed the
service of Mandalore and apparently
rendered it unbreathable and inoperable
but it's totally fine
um and then under water they saw the the
mythosaur right that one potentially
alive it looked like it was alive and
the methosaur is meant to be the is that
the cartoon animal that dinosaur that
Boba Fett was riding in the Star Wars
cartoon and no that I I know I don't I
don't Banff man
the [__] up man bamf uh it is it's not
the same it is not the same not the same
alien yeah but the mythosaurus this it's
the skull that has become the totem for
the mandalorians right
um why couldn't it have been the big
dinosaur that the cartoon Boba Fett hits
is like shut up
why don't you give me the salads yeah
the one person they're never gonna call
for a Star Wars show is the guy that was
just like those Death Star contractors
man
except that's what [__] Andor is
ultimately it's like it's it's all that
conversation I saw Tony Gilbert actually
said he was like remember that
conversation in clerks and I was like I
feel so seen
I Star Wars influenced me and then
inadvertently I influenced [__]
stories it's a causal Loop
um and episode three of Mando yeah I
[__] love I mean look I like the
first two episodes
um but the third one was a real big
departure because it looked like it
opens with like hey previously on on
Mando like the [__] that just happened
and then they [__] off and then it just
becomes a show about the one imperial
guy who was in the first season right
the Doctor Who was working on cloning Dr
Pershing who wanted broke his blood to
recreate something that we never knew
just cure the clickers from The Last of
Us
absolutely and so it then becomes like
it's very much like hey we could do and
or [__] too on Mandalorian can't we I
guess so so here's 25 30 minutes of just
this little story about this guy being
repatriated back into into the new
public Society the amnesty the amnesty
uh project or something like that the
idea is these are Imperials that with
the new Republic they were like well you
know just because you were a part of it
doesn't mean you were necessarily bad so
we're going to put you into this program
and make you New Republic citizens sort
of reconditioned the Empire out of you
and make you rehabilitate you back into
something very cool idea super cool idea
and so basically it's a story about
entrapment where young Dr Pershing is
like meets this young woman who was also
I think on off Gideon's ship yeah season
season one or two season two I think
where she was a Giddy and flunky and uh
and so she was on the previously they
showed her I was like I can't remember
her yeah kinda and uh maybe I think she
was on the show I forgot because Luke
sky worker showed up right so she's just
tempting him to be like don't you want
to do what you used to do couldn't that
be a good thing for the new Republic I
did cloning and nobody wants cloning but
you could be happy you could contribute
you could do this stuff so she's kind of
[__] honey trapping him into stealing
some [__] from an old Imperial ship and
she's the one who not even like drops
dime on him she's part of a program to
suss out
um
Unfaithful amnesty people who are not
going to act against the New Republic is
that what you got from it like she's
working for the news she's like 21 Jump
Street for real like she's like I'm
gonna go into this high school I'm gonna
sell that kid some weed and then I'm
gonna [__] tell her that he's the kid
I bought the weed from he's gonna bring
me to his deal right yes no maybe so not
sure I didn't get that I thought maybe
she was just like still Imperial or you
know still kind of like [__] this guy
because he [__] us over but I didn't
your take on it was she works for the
new Republic 100 is that because when
the cops show up she just literally like
stands from next to him to next to the
new Republic guys like he's your man
I didn't get that I'm so not smart yeah
what's up Ernie
Ernie needs one second
hey is there Mike Baker in the audience
Mike Baker head out to the lobby real
quick we got something going on that
requires your attention
can you fly a plane everything went so
[__] quiet
um okay back to yes back to Mando
um so like I I dug it but I don't know
it's like [__] Mando was such a weird
show in that sometimes they will tell
you stories that are very crucial to the
Mandalorian narrative in other TV shows
like there's two episodes of Boba Fett
that have nothing to do with Boba Fett
right that are entirely about [__]
mandu and grogu and Luke Skywalker and
Ahsoka Tano and do not connect at all
with the Boba Fett story [__] it let's
just bury it in this show wait which
show did Luke show up on it shows up in
season two finale of Mando that was
where he like [__] that's when he
destroys everybody the greatest one of
the greatest scenes in Star Wars history
absolutely what was the oh it was when
that we've catch up with him and he's
training grogu right that was on Boba
Fett yeah you know and so it's like
Mando's got the dark saber wants to get
back into the [__] Hood with the the
other Mandos and it's like well you got
her [__] did you take your helmet off
like yeah well you gotta purify yourself
in the waters of Lake minnow [__]
mandaloria and uh and she's like yeah
but make the this [__] Armor I
shouldn't have a best guard spear
because that's not a weapon of a [__]
Mando make my little tiny cute armor for
love little baby buddy can you make me
somebody please and so she's like [__]
it I will make this giant spear into the
cutest little bit of armor that you've
ever seen which he hasn't worn yet has
he he did he wears it in the end of in
Boba before in Boba Fett because it's
under his clothes it's very [__]
Hobbit is she always wearing it is that
the idea I I guess I don't know if
[__] grogus ever take off their
clothes
that's what I'm waiting for yes let me
see that Yoda dick
um I enjoyed that part on the glass put
the what was it two where like he has to
go get Bo Katan and he runs and jumps
into the ship and he just points to the
screen yeah and R5 is just like boys I
guess all right we'll go there which is
so what a stretch man like you're an
Astromech Droid and you're trained to
like do your gig and then like this
little creature comes in doesn't tell
you what to do just points to the screen
and you're like should I listen to him
or the other guy who won't take off his
helmet like [__] both of these people
um but like I I dug it but it's just
it's a weird digression unless what's
gonna happen is Dr Pershing is going to
be the dude who eventually reclones
Palpatine like that's how Palpatine
somehow returns
is that I said I'm just that's just a
guess that's just a guess I love your
version of Star Wars
um that would be cool that'd be a way to
like uh retcon and make it kind of
better I mean it seems like it looked
like they're Friday oh man
um I will uh I will also jump in and say
the next Disney plus series coming up is
Ahsoka
in which Grand Emerald thrawn is known
to play a big role in Grand Emerald
thrawn's whole thing in the books was
cloning
so it could also tie into everything
we're about to find out in the Ahsoka
series if
uh Dave filoni who created Ahsoka and is
a proud lover of the expanded universe
actually goes that direction which I
would bet on
proud lover right
also did you guys see online that that
in episode one that Shard of kryptonite
or whatever that has the inscription on
it in Mando the green rock
um that was translated and it is
um
from a Bible verse in Book of Exodus
part of Exodus 10 colon 5-6 about the
plague of locusts and the Jews fleeing
Egypt
and a lot of people are drawing
parallels between
uh the Mandalorian and the Jewish faith
and his journey through
to what you know Old Testament type
stuff which is really super interesting
I'm not going to speak on it because I'm
ignorant
also I don't know that a guy named
rafenberg should be talking about the
Jewish baby
but good [__] looking out man [__]
give it up for Banff man always [__]
way more Star Wars than the rest of us
I was hoping it was going to be some
[__] Ezekiel [__] like the path of
the righteousness was set upon he's like
we've translated it's from Pulp Fiction
uh so yeah I mean listen I'm I I remain
a person who's gonna watch the
Mandalorian
um I'm just constantly puzzled by some
of the storytelling choices even if like
oh it's cool just why is this in this
show like if that's going to be that
segment that leads into [__] Ahsoka
show why is it in the Ahsoka show what
like and I get the trying to build a
universe that is all cohesive and all
kind of webbed together with the same
token like they're just some people who
want to watch Mando and like did not
want to have to because I've never shown
my wife was like I want to watch
Mandalorian season three okay first we
gotta watch these three episodes of
[__] Boba Fett like why I don't know
what you do
and so we did and I'm like why are these
[__] here I'm gonna make one more
play for the fact that uh who's the
Imperial what's her does anybody know
the characters man what's the name of
the character that uh was the Double
Agent the 21 Jump Street
bam uh I have not seen all of episode
three yet I fell asleep
because I was watching last what oh yeah
tell them why you fell asleep he's
working real hard man uh I was at South
by Southwest all week and then I um
uh Jen went to Portland for a little
mini mom vacation and uh so I was taking
care of the kid
and uh and I had to choose between
watching binge watching The Last of Us
the last four episodes of that before
the show or Mandalorian and I decided to
our Wars lost to the guy with the Star
Wars bar
sorry not Star Wars
um I mean it's kind of the same show in
a way
I just wanted to see Pedro Pascal
literally they should have the same star
yeah
um I'm gonna make a play though for
um in in episode three like uh that
character talks about like going to the
decommissioned Imperial ships and that's
where she got like [__] cookies that
he likes yeah [__] uh Velveeta
[__] Imperial biscuits and [__]
and so at the end of the episode when
she turned when she because that's the
other thing I don't think she works for
the new Republic or she's like
pretending she works for the new
Republic what my read of it was she was
still deeply Imperial because the One
Republic guy walks away and then she
dials up Dr pershing's thing the free to
fry his brain and then eats one of those
Imperial biscuits which I got her to I I
took it to me and then like oh I'm
Imperial all the way see I don't think
that either those don't have to be
mutually exclusive true I think she
could still be a new Republic stooge who
is still secretly loyal to the to the
yeah yeah but I think more Imperial than
New Republic like just playing it low
low key until the rise of the empire
again that's what I read from it was
just like oh I'm Imperial all the way
I'm eating these [__] biscuits these
are the same biscuits Darth Vader would
have eaten if he ever took his [__]
mask off and [__]
um is that all for Mandalorian that's
all for Mandalorian uh give it up for
the Mandalorian chat kids
I do have a little bit of Star Wars news
though oh really yeah and it's just it's
my personal Star Wars news I uh I wrote
a Star Wars comic book
are you serious yeah for Dark Horse or
Marvel for Marvel yeah they reached out
and they have this this Darth Vader uh
black white and red mini series that
they're doing and uh they're like do you
want to write a Darth Vader story I was
like [__] yeah I want to write a Darth
Vader story and so it's coming out in
June I think but they just the solicits
went out last week so I don't have to
keep a secret anymore
look at that [__] man that's impressive
it is the closest I've come to having my
name in that blue type on a on a black
star field there are two hosts of fat
man beyond and one of them has been
talking about Star Wars in his movies
for 30 [__] years and they're like
let's ask the other guy to write a comic
book uh Mark is also a comic book writer
and that's what uh we should point out
too if you're in the New Jersey area of
the metropolitan area New York New
Jersey Pennsylvania or anywhere on the
East Coast uh tomorrow Saturday Mark is
going to Jay and Silent Bob's secret
stash and he's signing Adora in the
distance his book that he wrote as well
as anything else you put in front of him
and stuff
um so come on out man that's free as
[__] it's from noon till when noon to
three it's noon till three tomorrow
Jameson Bob Secrets how many people in
the audience are going to that
foreign
[__] leave now
um holy [__] man so like is it
considered will it be considered Canon
uh I I think so really I think so
so there's a chance that one day down
the road like they'll rip your [__] off
for a Mandalorian or something like that
all I want is one character who's got a
name to be in something else
that happened to me this week oddly
enough uh there's a show Superman and
Lois
um they they on the show they included
the character of onomatopoeia that me
and Phil Hester created for that in
Green Arrow and and rolled it into
Batman
and um
I don't know if it's necessarily the
same exact version it may be a gender
swapped version and it also looks like
it was a weird Flex to bring into the
Superman Universe because my version of
that character was just a serial killer
who just spoken on a metapoetics would
just say blam and then shoot you in the
face and stuff it looks like they're
using the character as more super
powered and it's an oral thing a-u-r-a-l
um but it was crazy to [__]
see that in the episode I was just
watching the episode and all of a sudden
I was like what the [__] where's my
check instant life that's the [__]
first thing I thought I was like oh my
God I'm finally gonna be rich and uh I
reached out to Phil Hester and I was
like hey man [__] onomatopoeia is on
[__] Superman Lois we could [__]
retire as it isn't there a form because
there's a form that you got to fill out
and send in I think it's for both DC and
Marvel that whenever they use like a
character that you've created for the
comics in other media you get a piece of
like the the character and for all time
if they make merchandise or anything
like that so I was like Phil we're gonna
be rich and Phil goes I had two
characters on Arrow for years and I
never made he goes I made 65 so
but that 65 is gonna be the sweetest
money I ever spent man but it looks like
the character is going to be ongoing uh
which is kind of cool and it was cool to
see like they did a version of The Mask
which looked like the the [__]
masking stuff is kind of dope
um all right where do we want to go next
uh let's see time for news time we could
do news we can talk about women
yeah man prepared and everything have
you seen any of History the world part
two yet no I saw of course history of
the World Part One in this theater when
I was a kid
my parents brought me to it and stuff
and [__] like had a hard time
explaining the erection joke uh with the
eunuchs and whatnot first they had to
explain Unix and then they had to
explain why one of the eunuchs got hard
to explain oh my God absolutely
um but they did sequelize it recently
and it's on Hulu is that it's on Hulu I
think it's like 10 episodes long is Mel
Brooks involved he uh he is apparently
he's he introduces every episode and
he's the kind of the voiceover artist
who introduce each segment and it's
[__] it's rapid fire they do not
spend much time at all in anything so
it's like hey we're gonna do Noah for
five minutes and then now we're gonna do
this World War II story and now we're
gonna do [__] the dude events the
phone and now we're gonna do it's just a
churns and like not everything is funny
but if they throw enough [__] at you
like half of it is and it becomes at you
fast enough feels pretty good
um I'm enjoying it are you really having
a good time having a good time with it
because it's dumb [__] done well
and the cast is ridiculous like because
who they got I mean Seth Rogen is
playing [__] Noah went to Brunson is
in it um who else did I say I mean Nick
Kroll is the kind of the the dude who's
kind of masterminding it so he's in like
every third sketch Mastermind meaning
he's one of the writers he's one of the
writers executive producers show owners
of it that's crazy so do you think it
came down to him going like I've always
wanted to see part two
I think some of it was Mel I think some
of it was was was was Nick and I Ike
Barenholtz also apparently is like one
of those guys and Wanda Sykes I think
they're the three who were the ones who
were like let's [__] do this and I
was like yeah let's [__] do this how
many episodes I think it's ten and how
many have you seen so far I've seen four
and worth watching yeah because it goes
down super [__] easy how long are
each episode 28 minutes oh is that right
yeah okay yeah man it's good times uh
there it is man A show worth checking
out history of the World Part Two that
only took [__] 40 years
your part three will come yes that means
there's hope for like Buckaroo Banzai
versus the world crime syndicate uh you
tell me sir
not on my watch
um what else you got should we do some
news [__] yeah man we're about to jump
into the news kids Mark Bernardin before
he was writing [__] Star Wars comics
and [__] uh was an old uh news hound man
it came from the world of news
Entertainment Weekly Hollywood Reporter
Playboy Playboy yeah a lot of news in
that magazine I'm told
um but uh every once in a while those
journalists against stinks kick in and
so now is one of those times here now
with the news is Mark Bernard give it up
for Mark
hmm
[Applause]
in what might have been the worst kept
secret in Hollywood uh James Gunn is
directing his Superman movie that came
out this week and that came out this
week he had there had been a leak I
think like Tom King went on some podcast
and mentioned that James was directing
it and then that episode of the podcast
went down Warner Brothers scrubbed it
from the Internet only for James to come
out like four days later I'm like yeah
all right I'm directing Superman
um it's called Superman Legacy Superman
Legacy coming out July 11th 2025. he put
up a tweet that I saw that was really
kind of uh sentimental as [__] where it
what is it what's the date it's uh yeah
it's July 11 2025 and his brother wrote
to him and said yeah that's my brother
Matt said when he saw the release date
this is just I copied and pasted from
his tweet it's like dude uh when he he
saw the release date he started to cry
and I asked him why he said dude that's
Dad's birthday oh I hadn't realized
awesome it's been a long road to this
point I was offered Superman years ago I
initially said no because I didn't have
a weigh-in that felt unique and fun and
emotionally gave Superman the dignity he
deserved then a bit less than a year
later that I bet less than a year ago I
saw a weigh-in in many ways centering
around his Superman's Heritage how both
his
aristocratic Kryptonian parents and his
Kansas former parents inform who he is
and the choices he makes so he chose to
finally take on writing a script but I
was hesitant to direct despite the
constant pestering by Peter Safran and
others to commit just because I write
something doesn't mean that I Feel It In
My Bones visually and emotionally enough
to spend over two years directing it
especially not something that's
magnitude but the long and short of it
is I love the script and I'm incredibly
excited as we begin this journey good
for him man I mean James is crazy
[__] talented definitely one of the
best of us certainly not the last of us
um but that's really that's really
[__] sweet man you know James is
known for like weirder stuff and to see
him taking on an American icon I'm
curious to see what he does with it is
there any word like I heard that it it's
not Clark Kent it may be Jonathan Ken
did you hear that or is that a dream
ahead uh it might be a dream you had
[__]
um yeah I mean all else is news on the
internet the dream that I had Silent Bob
had a dream
um but yeah I mean all that they've said
about the Superman is that he's a
younger Superman probably in his 20s as
opposed to an older women's 40s which is
part of what precipitated the casting of
Henry Cavill the recast
um but that's [__] exciting you're
right he's a he's an extraordinarily
talented filmmaker and I think he knows
the mission brief which is you got to
make a [__] Superman you're not going
to make like dick jokes Superman you got
to make [__] Superman right and what
that means
um in this day and age and so like I'm
[__] curious man if there's a job
opening for dick joke Superman I would
really love to throw my hat into the
ring
um that's awesome I can't wait to see I
mean look it's they're doing a wonderful
version of Superman uh with Superman and
Lois and I say that because they
included onomatopoeia
um but it'll be nice to see Superman uh
back on the big screen I loved what
Henry Cavill did when they dropped that
Flash trailer I guess during the Super
Bowl and they showed the Zod I was like
holy [__] man like for some reason I
knew like I'd read Michael Shannon was
in it but then when I saw him in the
trail I was like this is [__] genius
and it made me go back and watch Man of
Steel again and I really had like uh I
appreciated the first time around but I
Newfound appreciation for what he did
with the character uh but I'm you know
I'm an old school Superman fan it's I
love Batman to death but Batman is like
a child's wish right like and also the
realistic superhero that we could all
aspire to be because it doesn't he
doesn't have super powers or anything
you just have to watch your parents die
in an Alleyway and then have a lot of
money and you could be Batman and stuff
but you refuse therapy at every time
exactly like you sure you don't want to
see a therapist no
uh voice is interesting for a 12 year
old yes uh Superman though of course
like the very first uh superhero
um you know always stands for something
bigger and and better it's the thing you
could never be the ideal
um I within the last six months at one
point like I was defending
um actions that I took with Jordan uh
who runs our company Jason Muse's wife
Jordan Monsanto and I was like well I
can't just like do nothing man because
like Superman that's what he did he
wouldn't sit there and listen she was
saying like you can't just sit with
somebody's pain she's like you and Jason
are the exact same
um Jason Muse and she was like and I
said well we both came from Highlands it
must be in the water and she goes you
neither of you could sit with someone's
pain like you feel the need to do
something she's like in Jason's case
they got an eight-year-old daughter
Logan and whenever Logan cries about
something Jason will turn the world
upside down to stop her from crying
he'll do [__] anything and she's like
if you would just wait five minutes
she's eight like five minutes from now
it won't bother her whatever [__]
bothers her and she's like you're the
exact same way and I was like no man
well I was like like [__] I do you
think Superman would sit there with
somebody's pain of course like he would
want to help and do something and she's
like Kevin Superman's not real
like that's what makes him so wonderful
as a character is he's an ideal we'll
never reach for and stuff so I look
forward to see what James does the
character think of all the heart that he
brought to the Guardians of the Galaxy
movies which when first announced it was
just like they're doing that Marvel's
over and [__] and yet he found a way to
bring incredible heart to those first
two movies and it looks like from the
trailer for the third one even more
heart to the [__] third episode so I
can't wait to see what he does with
Superman
um you know pun intended he will make
Superman sewer I have utmost confidence
in that well I believe a man can fly
yeah no yeah we will it was a great
marketing campaign man like that can you
imagine like there was a simpler time in
19 I guess 78 was when Superman came out
where that was the they built the whole
marketing campaign said you will believe
a man can fly based on the fact that
they're flying effects were gonna look
cool and and now today of course the
standard's much higher James won't get
away with like you will believe a man
could fly like I believe that [__] on CW
you know [__] bring something more to
the table but I'm sure he'll bring
something more to the table but what a
weird life it must be like as Guardians
of the Galaxy is preparing to come out
to still be like yeah I gotta wrap up my
Marvel life before I start this whole DC
life and I'm sure you know there's no
like with the audience and fans and
whatnot they there's like they it must
be you know [__] an inner struggle a
combat between the two I don't think so
at all I think this is a guy who just
loves [__] comic books and stuff so
he's wrapping up his tenure in one
universe and then starting another I
look forward to see what he does yeah I
mean most common fans at least the ones
that I know today are not they're
someone agnostic about where the comics
come from you know there had been some
Allegiance back in the days you Marvel
you DC so you [__] beetles are
Rolling Stones
but not so much anymore like it's just
do you like Comics yeah do you like good
Comics sometimes like then all right you
can come sit by me
that's fine I like that
um elsewhere yes did uh anybody like the
willow show that was on uh Disney plus
anybody see the willow show those on
Disney Plus
she loved it
well you're not getting any more
is that right they're not doing it again
no was it a one and done series or was
there like no they had plans for a
second season a willow verse well I
don't know if there's a much will verse
is just more Willow
um but they they have since pruned
Willow is that right yeah another
casualty of the streaming Wars there
will be no second season of Willow uh
Disney's plus is live action original
series based on the 1998 fantasy film
directed by Ron Howard
um comes two months after the eight
episode first season premiered uh it did
not only ever broke the top 10 in the
streaming uh I didn't even know it came
out when did it when did it first start
airing
um I think what are we now this is we're
in March so I think it was like December
really yeah yeah I didn't hear anything
about it yeah I have Disney Plus
um I mean it got pretty decent reviews
but I just don't think that that
ultimately there was an audience that
was clamoring for it it's the same thing
for theatrical Willow when it came out
like you know got an okay reception but
it wasn't it didn't go huge and and I've
never met somebody who's like I [__]
die for Willow so I was shocked when
they said we're going back did Ron
Howard do it or no uh no uh Jake kazden
did it
um and I think Lawrence might have had
something to do with the script for the
first Willow and so he came back and and
was the show owner for the second the
willow TV series but
I just guessed that that Disney is
beginning to under the new leadership of
the old guy Bob Iger re-examine what
they're spending their money on
um because it's like that's a lot of
money for a TV show that either not many
people were asking for I'm sorry
um or very many people watched and so
and you know show like that shooting
overseas for [__] however long
there's just like a 100 million dollar
TV show and that's a lot of money to
spend on something that gets you no new
subscribers and they can't actually sell
and won't sell any merch for and I think
that that's sort of part of the new wave
of Disney is
can we make money on this they've said
the same time Bob Iger I think somewhere
talked about like we're going to
re-examine Marvel as well and Star Wars
in terms of like how much quantity that
they're putting out there
um I guess you know obviously they
weren't happy with the Returns on
Quantum Mania so I don't know how that
affects the Marvel Universe going
forward if they slow that down a little
bit like they've slowed down Star Wars
like they just announced what last week
or two weeks ago the movie like The
Patty Jenkins
Star Wars movie is never happening right
the Kevin feige Star Wars movie is
apparently now never happening and the
one that they're holding on to is
whatever taika watiti is doing they've
got rid of the Benny off and Weiss Star
Wars thing like at the end of The Game
of Thrones they were like these guys are
doing Star Wars and they're like nope
not so much yeah I think Damon Lindelof
is still co-writing a Star Wars movie
but there's been no word of what that is
or when it's coming they seem to be very
much more invested in TV and even there
beginning to sort of pull back a little
bit do you think that you know I know
they look I've loved watching the
Mandalorian I loved watching uh Boba
Fett and whatnot do you think if you're
getting it at home for on Disney plus
that maybe it's you're just like yeah
I'm star warsed out you think it has
that effect on the theatrical version I
think it might but the only way they
really make money on it is if it's a
movie
is that what do you mean explain because
you've already at this point if you were
going to subscribe to Disney plus you
subscribe to Disney plus right and
they're getting your 11.99 or whatever
it is it costs already so by putting out
Skeleton Crew or putting out a silver
whatever that is there's not a new
audience who's suddenly like that's the
one I was here for yeah nobody's next
time and or now I'm [__] on board
it's just you rang my bell [__]
here's my money I don't think that's the
case so they can't really make new money
off of spending
90 million dollars on a new Star Wars
show whereas if they make one movie
that's 600 million dollars of box office
potentially yeah that they get to make
and so I think there's going to be a bit
of a shift back into movies for Star
Wars and a Slowdown on Star Wars series
because it's it's you're preaching to
the choir at this point
it's weird because this is a world I
always dreamed of right where it's like
more Star Wars more Marvel more [__]
everything and now there's so much that
like I I haven't caught up on all of it
it's hard to be part of the problem you
are Kev
um it's hard to be nostalgic for a thing
you get all the time and Star Wars is a
Nostalgia driven Enterprise and if I
don't ever get a chance to miss it then
how do I hunger for it that's true like
between the end of Return of the Jedi
and like you know not counting Ewok
movies on TV and stuff what was the next
thing they did the re-releases in like
the 90s yeah
15 years later and there was like all
this fervency of like I remember Star
Wars was a thing that was done when
Disney bought Star Wars I my first
thought was like how weird why would you
spend billions of dollars on a movies
that are done and you would never make
another one of because I have no vision
whatsoever
and then all of a sudden they're like oh
we're gonna make Star Wars we're gonna
give you more [__] Star Wars and you
can shake a stick out or a lightsaber
and now it seems to be biting him a bit
in the ass
yeah I mean I think and some of that was
also that when we were in a pandemic
the only thing that people could do is
watch [__] on streamers right so that
was and the only way you could judge a
company's Health was by the number of
subscribers they had for their streamers
so everybody just poured money into it
and then the World opened back up again
and maybe people stop watching as much
on streamers and then people were going
back to the movies and spending money
again
and they've already spent the money they
were going to spend on Star Wars
apparently the the season premiere I
don't know how they do ratings now in
this world with digital but there's one
site that is able to do a kind of
nielsen-like rating version of what's
going on like in the world of streaming
but according to that site which you
know I again isn't like the network
reporting it but they said that the
season premiere of Mandalorian was down
by like a million or something like that
didn't have as many people as Obi-Wan
Kenobi had and didn't have as much even
as Boba Fett
so yeah I don't it seemed like when we
first started watching the Mandalore
he's like oh my God they'll be doing
this for 40 years straight because even
if Pedro Pascal is not doing it it's
John Wayne's grandson his great grandson
as well but it might be that they ran
they pull the reins in on that as well
maybe we get a lot less Mandalorian than
we thought we were ever going to get
could be maybe they they decide that
there's an ending to this story
yeah against their will they're like you
know end this [__] yeah come on bring it
bring it home I thought we'd watch grogu
grow up and become a teenager and
[__] an adult and [__] but that
mother
Amy Sedaris in episode two is like he
said my name but I think she was just
making a joke right and also I did we
talk about the fact that apparently he
was grogu was training with Luke for two
years is that how long it was according
to Fabs that's how long that he's with
Luke the show doesn't tell you that it
feels like it's like next Thursday yeah
the [__] man I was like I miss that
little son of [__] let me go get him
back
no that was two years worth of Story
Time what happened in those two years he
didn't learn to speak
what the [__]
not even backwards or broken like Yoda
yeah like you gotta get the kind of
speech I can or anything like that
um what else we got
um remember there was a there was a
Batman television program that uh bruced
him and Ed brubecker were doing for
Warner Brothers wasn't that the one that
uh were you I had a little something to
do with it
um so you remember I remember quite well
because they paid me money
um but uh HBO maxed 65 oh I bought like
six bags of Doritos
but HBO Max decided they didn't want to
air it and so Warner Brothers animation
kept producing it and so now uh it's at
Amazon
has ordered two seasons of Batman Caped
Crusader oh [__] so wait is
your episode I mean as far as I know
they haven't told me that I don't have
an episode anymore so you're gonna your
screenplay will be produced yeah I think
it's already in the words because they
never stopped producing it like Warner
Brothers animation all right nice give
it up for Mars
um yeah back when the you know HBO Max
began in the streaming wars were in
their Earnest everybody took their IP
in-house and they're like we're not
[__] selling this anymore other
people the model always used to be like
you know you could make a thing sell it
to somebody else Warner Brothers didn't
necessarily have to put it out they
could be the producers of it but like it
could air other places and now it's you
know after
the constriction it feels like they're
going back to the old model because what
they realize is like we make a lot more
money
selling our [__] to other people rather
than just putting it on our Channel
because to to your point anybody who
wants that thing is probably already
getting that thing right so I mean it's
it's odd to imagine a world in which
Batman is airing on a non-warner
Brothers uh outlet but they gotta make
that [__] money they're looking for
that [__] Bezos money right there man
the only person who could afford
billionaire Bruce Wayne is [__] Jeff
Bezos zillionaire Jeff Bezos and for
Amazon it's super smart because now they
can sell a bunch of Batman merch using a
new cartoon because you ever watch
something on Amazon little x-ray feature
pops up and they can just drive you
right to their store where it's like hey
you want to buy some Batman comic books
you want to buy some Batman merch you
wanna buy some shirts and [__]
slippers Underoos whatever we got two
seasons of this show did they do that
with their shows ready they eat
sometimes yeah like I've been like
people watch the man in the high tower
or whatever and they'll like buy these
paper towels just like he uses
well it's it's less it's less yet or
don't buy laundry detergent while you're
watching handmade sale but
but I think that they could sell you
Batman [__] I think they also have uh
gotten the rights to the original Batman
the Animated Series so now they have a
Batman [__] Suite that they could
what Amazon Prime did yeah so that's no
longer I don't think it's exclusive to
HBO Max anymore wow so now they can be
the home of all things Batman fair
enough they're not [__] around the
business has changed right in front of
our eyes and then changed again back
right in front of her eyes indeed I have
two more stories one of which I think
you'll like and one of which is a is a
bit of a sad bit of news it broke today
uh the first one it's a little old also
is that uh your boy John Bernthal
he's back as The Punisher in the new
Daredevil born again
um I'm all for it he was absolutely
wonderful in the Netflix version uh but
it's gonna be weird to be like Disney's
Punisher
he's mad but not that mad yeah it's it's
gonna be like the Terminator in T2 just
lots of [__] like Just Wing him yeah
I gotta kill him so much just [__]
wound him
um what is the uh he's on the Daredevil
proper show yes
all right I mean I'm all for it I just
how hard can Disney plus go what's the
hardest they've gone do they have an
R-rated equivalent or anything
um I mean they have the rights to all of
the old Netflix stuff that they now have
they're hosting on Disney plus
um I don't know how hard this show is
gonna go I think it's got a very legal
emphasis but yeah I don't know I don't
know and Deadpool 3 is going to be a
Disney release
so and they're not [__] around with
that like that's an R-rated movie it's
like the other two like the other two so
I guess we'll see well that's awesome uh
yeah I saw a number of people returning
from uh the Netflix show except they
didn't bring back foggy and Karen yet
yeah anything's possible yeah that's
true
um and our last bit of news broke today
um incredibly sad news is Lance Reddick
who played Sharon in all four John Wick
movies he was in The Wire Fringe Bosch
on a hundred other [__] things the
last 25 years passed away today
the guy from The Wire the guy from The
Wire 60 years old
in the middle of this young and he was
always so healthy
um all right let's look healthy yeah
yeah but he's 60 years old he was in the
middle of the John Wick 4 press tour
which is coming out next weekend I think
yeah it's here I'm sure it will open
with four people in the audience but yes
John Wick's coming out yeah no we expect
that to actually be big so he was out
there doing press he was out there doing
press passed away and passed away and I
mean it says natural causes but they're
not providing any other details and it's
I mean it's still a developing story he
just passed away today oh my god um but
yeah like and he was in a bunch you've
heard his voice a thousand times he was
in the Rick and Morty vindicators
episode as the ghost train right the
ghost train guy yeah he was in the Mass
Effect games he was in the destiny games
he was in so great on Fringe but yeah
it's amazing on The Wire the wire is I
mean everybody was in The Wire will
always have the wire as The Shining
thing on their resume yeah you're
certain degree no matter what else they
did because it was at least until
Breaking Bad the Undisputed best show
that had ever been on TV yeah and even
now it's still a little bit of a toss-up
but you know young dude who left his
Mark 60 is far too [__] young way too
young man jeez but yeah so not to bring
us down uh for the end of the show but
we'll get to [__] q a and you guys
will bring us back up again but um poor
went out for Lance Reddick who did a ton
of [__] give it up for Lance we're
out of kids
[Applause]
thank you
um there's one more bit of news I don't
have it in front of me but uh the cover
story of The Hollywood Reporter your
alma mater indeed uh this week is uh Ben
Affleck promoting uh air his movie which
I've heard is amazing I'm gonna go see
the premiere on the 27th um
but he did a very Ben Affleck type
interview one of the things I've always
loved about Ben is how insanely [__]
candid he is
um and uh you know I'm always kind of
open and forthright and stuff I'm sure I
stole a bit of it from him early on uh
because when he would like sit in front
of the press he would just open up and
he's so well read and so well spoken and
stuff so this article provided a bunch
of context for uh not just uh air the
movie that he directed with with Matt in
it but um he talked about
uh justice league and Batman v Superman
and stuff and he talked about
um they asked him like Hey you're gonna
are you gonna direct like because I
guess James Gunn had said like Ben's not
coming back as Batman but like he's
talking about directing a thing and he
was like no like flat out was like No
And he was like I've got nothing against
James Gunn and whatnot but he's like I
won't be doing that at all uh he went
hard in his dedication for Zack Snyder
he was just like if if Zach ever returns
to that he's going I'm right or die was
Zack Snyder uh he loved Batman v
Superman but he talked about the Justice
League experience and um and what a like
uh trying Beyond trying time for him it
was in his life in the piece he talks
about how when they were you know he I
don't know if he referenced Joss Whedon
but he referenced Joss Whedon without
referencing Joss Whedon perhaps by
saying that there was a guy who was like
you know hey man I know what the problem
with this movie is and if you give me 60
million bucks in two months I can solve
it for you and he was like he didn't and
he talked about being overseas for it
and that was where he lost his desire to
direct a Batman movie or or be involved
in that area of the business now he
seems to be going back in the direction
of his Argo and Gone Baby Gone stuff but
he talked about like um during the uh
experience of making Justice League or
not making the original Justice League
with Zach which he pointed out is now
retroactively his highest rated movie on
IMDb he's like according to the IMDb the
best movie I ever made was Zack Snyder's
Justice League but he talked about while
making the reshoots of Justice League
with uh with Whedon that he got into a
very despondent place and he's very
Frank talking about his drinking and he
talked about like it was either drink or
jump out a [__] window and that's
some deep [__] [__] right there man
I'm because people were like how come
Ben's not making that movie and he told
us flat out in the Press It's a
Wonderful article worth reading because
again he's always candid and really
interesting and so well spoken but uh I
read that piece cover to cover number
one looking for a reference to me and
there was none
um but number two I just always love to
follow his press because he does it
differently than anybody else and that I
thought was incredibly Soul bearing uh
but man I would hate to be Joss Whedon
today
um I I Adore any day for that matter
he's not having a great decade no
um but my my accent of my following Ben
Affleck's press is when I discovered
that he speaks fluent Spanish yeah and
so watching him do Spanish press and
then seeing the interviewers be
astonished that [__]
okay yeah
and just he's in the complete package
man he's honestly like I love being
Kevin Smith but the only person I would
like to be in this life other than Kevin
Smith is Ben Affleck I've always
absolutely loved him but yeah he's so
[__] smart like you know you got to
remember his mom was like an English
teacher and stuff
um but he's he never stops growing and
changing and adding to the resume always
surprising uh to a lot of people except
those of us who've always known him so
when we were doing junkets for the
movies we did whenever I wasn't doing an
interview like you know they've got this
like kind of main control room where
they back in the day they had used to be
like eight TVs and now it's probably
laptops or something like that or one
monitor with eight screens that are kind
of embedded in but I would always go to
like Mission Control they call it just
to sit there and watch his interviews in
a junket situation you only get like
five minutes with people but he was
never reticent or quiet he would like
treat each one like with it with its own
degree of enthusiasm
um yeah he's one of my favorite people
on the planet and not just because like
I know him and he's a good guy but like
even if I didn't know the guy I would
always find him incredibly interesting
as somebody who goes out there and works
in this business is pretty candid about
it
um yeah that's I'm done blowing Ben
um well not forever just here
uh I'd like to meet him someday you
never met him no
how would I [__] met him
I said maybe over the years or something
like working that [__] thr or working
it I I don't like interviewing famous
people is that right yeah for the most
part
um because did they give you that choice
back in the day I started as a Critic
like my my first I was an editor and
then when I decided to start writing for
magazines I wrote as a Critic video
critic first comic books and then just
movies in general
um but then as I began to to to move on
in my career I could then kind of cherry
pick the kinds of things that I wanted
to do I really enjoyed editing stories
but every now and again I wanted to talk
to people but they were almost always
creators I wanted to talk to writers and
directors I never really wanted to talk
to actors because I
I didn't want to be part of whatever
narrative that they were telling about
the movie they were making right because
unlike Ben most of them are not candid
about what they're doing right
um and so it just always felt yeah and I
never liked uh the sound of my laugh
listening to it on the tape back when I
had to transcribe my own [__]
interviews because every laugh to a
famous person sounded like the fakest
laugh I'd ever heard I'm like next
question it's like oh God no that's how
you laugh at my [__] jokes man
next question you're a famous person
that's just what happens [__] um but I
think you were the first famous person
that I have ever interviewed
um for Entertainment Weekly and it was
the first time we ever met in you know
not even personally over the phone but
it was like oh well he's he's just
[__] like one of us he makes a thing
you know he's a Creator he's a writer
he's a director like he's under the hood
of this stuff and so we were just
talking about dumb superhero costumes
but at least it wasn't some exercise in
narcissism or vanity or whatever it was
kind of geeked out we nerded out trying
to do what we do here every week and
stuff yeah and so there was an even even
playing field I never had to struggle
with
all right Brad Pitt tell me how
difficult it was for you to make this
movie again but oh [__] it was hard
every morning waking up looking like
Brad Pitt
I can't empathize at all yeah I never
gave you that interview it's like bro
you don't know what I gotta go through I
uh I became uh something of a go-to guy
too like I remember first we talked and
then whenever you needed a geek quote
because there was a time before everyone
was fluent geek and in comic book movies
and [__]
um you would hit me up and be like hey
do you have a quote for this and I was
like well yes I do but one of the
sweetest things that Mark ever did for
me was uh and I've talked about before
but during the San Diego San Diego Comic
Con forget which year it was there's the
year right before 2008. so it was when
Zach Zach and Miri was coming out
um Mark had a panel that was what icons
or it was Visionary Visionaries
Entertainment Weekly presents The
Visionaries and he put it together a
panel of of Visionaries to speak to one
of them was Zack Snyder who had Watchmen
coming out yes one of them was Frank
Miller who of course had a spirit coming
out yes but also of course yeah but of
course you know the author of
Dark Knight Returns and or inarguably
the person who kind of reignited Batman
amongst other things and of course 300
and everything else one of them was Judd
Apatow who was like riding so [__]
high at that point and then Mark hit me
up and he goes do you want to be the
other guy and I was like just to have
one of these things is not like the
other
and he was like no you're a Visionary
and he put me on a panel particularly at
a time in my life where I was like
feeling like really low and way out of
the loop and stuff like that
um which I'll never forget man I'm not
like saying it saved my life but it
really did save my ego at that point to
be able to sit up there in front of a
Hall h with a bunch of cats who were
busy and vital and stuff and I was still
just kind of being me and stuff I love
the version that story that you tell
because you're missing a you continue to
miss a crucial part of that which is you
were the first person I asked to be on
that is that right and everybody else
said yes because you had already
committed to it you're gonna make me cry
is that right that's 100 what happened
oh my God
like they they no
I always thought you were like well I
can't get [__] anybody else I'll call
Kevin [__] no you you were the the
linchpin that got judged to say yes that
God Zach to say yes and then Frank I
think just showed up because I'm doing
the spirit and maybe there's I don't
know food in The Green Room
[Laughter]
and uh but no that's that's how that
came together because everything is
always when you're asking putting out an
ass like that for for Hollywood people
to do a thing they always want to know
who's already doing the thing because
nobody wants to be the first person to
be there because then it'll be like hi
I'm Judd Apatow and there's the guy who
directed Critters four
um but no that's that is 100 the way
that went down because they were like oh
Kevin will be there great it had one of
my that afforded me one of my favorite
moments in my career because uh when
when Judd exploded Judd was you know I
we you know I was an R-rated comedy guy
and there was this working theory in my
world of like well no R-rated comedy is
ever going to make more than 30 million
because that's all my movies ever did
was like 30 million and then the 40 year
old virgin Knocked Up or movies that Lit
way more than that and stuff and you
know I was like oh man Judd apatel is
making like better Kevin Smith movies
and making more money doing it [__] so
he was the king of R-rated comedy at
that point and so I was sitting next to
him on that panel and he at one point he
was just like well I'm only getting to
do what I do because Kevin Smith laid
the track and I was like oh my God like
it was everything I needed to hear in
that moment uh he's since moved way on
from that and [__] but and forgotten
that the tracks were ever laid but it
was a seminal moment in my [__]
career man wow that's so I didn't I
didn't it's not like I forget that part
of the story I had no idea I've told it
before well I mean it used to be a
stoner I forgot a lot of pigs Mark and
yeah so many potholes in the past this
is very many
um wow oh [__] I don't know how I'm
gonna do the rest of the show I feel so
warm inside
um okay we're done with the news done
with the news give it up for the news
and Mark Bernard ladies and gentlemen
foreign
two hours into this Banff man how are
things going online with uh chatter and
whatnot
bamf uh things online are good we've got
no uh unruly people uh people
uh are very angry with Mark for giving
Last of Us an A minus instead of an A
plus which I think is funny
why because it wasn't like an A plus or
just an a yeah they think it's like the
best show ever and he they're mad that
Mark didn't love uh didn't love it as
much as they did Even though Mark could
save the world and somebody would be
like yeah but what about Mars mark
hey minus is a huge [__] great
seriously guys like
science
you gave it like a 92 and they thought
it should have been a 97 you know
so
it's so awesome to sit next to you
because you're always seen as the person
that hates everything and I'm always
seen as the guy who loves [__]
everything you know and I like a thing
but just not enough
for Phil from was anyone mad at him for
liking Shazam as much as he did
no I don't know if anybody's seen Shazam
though like nobody was talking about it
in the chat Mark is the first person in
the U.S to see Shazam
[Laughter]
first and we already see it not it's mod
Castle [__] Cinemark
man I'm not gonna live that down am I no
actually based on what you just told me
you can go to Cinemark for the rest of
your [__] life in fact I'll pay for
you to go to Cinemark out of here
um all right so uh
and on to the Q a but we're moving on to
the Q a portion um when we do this show
uh in Hollywood at the scum and villainy
cantina with bamfam live and whatnot we
always get to pull questions from the
audience when we do it uh online you
know for the home shows of course uh JC
pulls from the the chat and stuff but
tonight we're gonna get to do it right
here uh with a live audience just like
we kind of do it at scum and villainy um
that's come ability we usually stand
people up against a wall and put a
camera on them and stuff so we don't
have a second camera and a wall but if
we pick you to do the question I think
you should come up here because
otherwise we're gonna have to repeat it
and [__] for everybody in the audience
so if you're going to ask a question
know that you're going to have to come
up here in front of uh the audience
which as you've seen it's a very
friendly audience it's only the online
audience that gets mad if you give
something an A minus
so uh let's start the Q a kids [__]
damn come on up here
yeah stairs over on this side
this is Jean everybody give it up for
Gina
so I know you guys were talking about
the last of us and it being obviously
based off of a video game is there a
video game that you would love to write
as either a series or a film
yeah
great question give it up for Gina
thank you Gina
start with you you seem to be way more
of a gamer than I've ever been in my
entire life I stopped playing games when
Atari went out of style yeah
um yeah once I don't think I've ever
played a first person shooter game I'm a
scroll guy you're a scroll guy and a
hockey guy remember you were playing
lots of yeah Sports it's in the game
um I think the one that I'd want to do
um with uh with a with a with a partner
would be there was a game that came out
I think mid pandemic called ghost of
tsushima
which is ultimately it's a Samurai game
right it's a you're you're a Wandering
Samurai who's got to avenge your your
dead father and you're traveling sashim
is this island off the coast of Japan
which itself is an island so it's you
know it's a it's an archipelago I
suppose
um is that how you pronounce that
archipelago yeah I just thought it was
like Archie pelago
but to be fair when I went to Los
Angeles for the first time I was uh
after like clerks got picked up me and
Scott Mosher went out together and uh he
was like where do we turn I was like we
turn on Sepulveda and he was like he was
such derision I talked to him about it
like last two weeks ago which it was
such division in his voice because he'd
been to Los Angeles many more times than
me and he was like Sepulveda
[Music]
I think Archie palego should be your
like witness protection name yes that's
my porn name Archie pelego
I've got a sausage delivery for you man
from Archie pelagos
um but no it's it's a it's a gorgeous
[__] game how do you say it again uh
archipelago
is that does everyone agree with that
I love that you're like I don't trust
you sir I'm gonna ask these 200 people
who all had English apparently
say it one more time archipelago
archipelago I gotta remember that even
when I read it I read it phonetically
well I mean I
I that's wrong too isn't it
I'm not a smart man I'm clever but I'm
not smart but it's it's everybody I
think has those words that they
encountered first in a book yes and
never heard it out loud true I honestly
feel like you're the first person that
ever said it out loud I remember very
distinctly encountering the word idiot
in a in a book and I pronounced it a
diode
all right now that's [__] dumb and
it's and it's perfect for the word yeah
like what did you say a diode idiot
you know what I gotta [__] record
this
Siri will tell you the same thing though
but it's just for my own future
reference all right this is my voice
memo say it again
archipelago
let me just play it back make sure it
works we just like trigger the Winter
Soldier or something
archipelago
it's gonna be my ringtone
okay back to the yeah but it's just it's
it's this gorgeous story it's just about
revenge and about understanding who you
are and about family loyalty and um but
it's a Kurosawa movie come to life and
so to do a to do a show like that to do
a TV show like that
I hey it's been a long time since it
seen a really good Samurai [__] TV
show which is part of the reason why I
would want a partner to do it so I can
find somebody uh who has way more of a
connection to that particular culture
but I just [__] loved it that game
that game and Last of Us Part Two got me
through like the first couple of months
of lockdown because I was just in
another place in time
um that was not this one
um and just getting to look [__] hack
and slash people to death because I had
some pent up frustration it takes a long
time to play a video game nowadays right
it's you know up for 20 minutes the
pitfall would no no well if you're good
at Pitfall you could play that I've
never made it to 20 minutes either uh
wait so how long does it take to play
that game that game was in 18 hours 18
19 hours to finish the campaign and when
you do something like that or you're
like leave me alone for the next day
until I finish the game no like I would
pay play it like you know hour Clips 90
minute Clips sometimes it'll be up too
late because I'm having too good of a
time but I can't Marathon that [__]
because I just my bladder isn't that big
anymore
um so so but and I just liked parceling
it out like it's like a really good book
that you don't want to just blast
through that you kind of want to get to
save her
um Last of Us games Last of Us Part Two
I think was like 30 some odd hours part
one is like 18 or 19 hours does the game
just something like the last of us
change when you go play it again or it's
always the same it's always the same
story you're always on Rails like it has
this feeling that you're in an open
world that you could adventure and
discover but it will always bring you
back to here's the here's the spine of
the story we're telling kind of like
that Dragon's Lair video game from the
80s and [__] yeah they always made you
feel like you put in a buck and [__] and
you hit the joystick once and then
[__] die and you're like wait a
second it felt like they dictated the
story not you very much so
um because you can only build so much of
that game there are games that are open
world that you can do anything in like
the Assassin's Creed games are huge
so that you can like yeah there's a main
story but you could just spend [__]
weeks just kind of discovering ancient
Egypt and here I'm in concert in opal
this is cool never been here before it
was a pirate game a pirate version of
Assassin's Creed called Black Flag where
you could spend as long as you wanted to
on the high seas destroying other pirate
ships and plundering their booty and not
playing a plot game at all just at that
point you're just about the booty
the uh uh Christian who's up in the
booth for us uh Christian Cortez he was
uh last night we were testing uh
Splinter here and then I came in later
on after I walked Mark out to his car
and
Christian are you there you got a mic
I'm here cat what what did you I was
watching the short film I was like what
is this and he goes there's a short film
I made and it was incredibly [__]
cinematic there were like Dolly shots
and [__] crane moves I was like how
did you [__] do this how did you make
that I made it using Grand Theft Auto 5.
that's that's a thing that's a very big
thing there's a whole community of
people who love to do it I taught myself
how to do it old and ignorant like
is that so you can there's a function of
the game where you just go make your own
movie it literally has its own director
mode so you can create characters you
can make stories I mean you're limited
by the pre-made animations in the game
right but if you play your cards right
and take the time to do it you can make
something really cool
and when did Grand Theft Auto come out
you said that's from number five when
did this all begin uh that came out in
2013 but I didn't start making movies
with that until maybe a couple months
ago so this [__] has existed for 10
years and last night was the first time
I heard that you could make a movie
Inside Grand Theft Auto
yeah pretty much
confirmed yes even bring it to the old
man but that's how they're rolling
um all right so that's your answer
that's my answer ghosts of sushima uh my
answer is there is a super uh no was it
no it was a Sega Saturn game
um no it wasn't even a Sega Saturn it
was Sega Genesis game called The
Adventures of Rocky and Bullwinkle
I would totally make that [__] game
oh my God you got to be Rocky you got to
be Bullwinkle like it was nuts you got
to do move some squirrel [__] yes
um let's go to Batman because I'm sure
he's a gamer bamf man you got a game
that you would have liked to see naked
bam for yourself
Oh weird it didn't put me on
huh oh you're here there we go
um I think if I had to be real about it
I would say
Legend of Zelda
would be my number one but I also think
that NBA Jam would be really fun like in
a in a Looney Tunes kind of Space Jam
way NBA Jam
what is it is it like you could put
together any team you want or something
it's two on two basketball but there
were all these like power ups and you
could like the ball would catch on fire
if you started like making a lot of
shots in a row and it's just so
endlessly playable and fun I think you
could make a really fun
like 90 minute comedy out of that like a
cartoon
buck and I
give it up her bath man good job
all right all right question number two
where do we go you pick I'm picking uh
that dude come on up
join us
what's your name captain
Markell come on up Marco give it up for
Markel
[Applause]
um so my question is um the show is
called Batman Beyond uh based on
obviously Batman Beyond so I was
wondering if you guys uh fast forward
into the future with your show and you
could choose your own Terry McGinnis you
have to choose a male or female or both
um and you don't know them so you can't
treat somebody that you know
I can't use it great question man give
it up
who's your Terry McGill and one I could
get my head around because I have
watched Batman Beyond
uh you go first though why you go first
[__]
all right so I'm old Bruce Wayne we're
both old Bruce Wayne
but in the model of Batman being Batman
Beyond we would have to be the old
versions of us are we bitter and
curmudgeonly like him or can we be happy
in our old age
so wait am I am I trying to pick a
superhero am I picking somebody to start
a podcast
and we can't know them
because Bruce Wayne didn't know Terry
although as we found out at the end of
the show he made Terry
so by virtue of that I guess Harley
would be my
my answer
um okay so we got to pick somebody that
presumably we don't know
um so is that mean
somebody whose podcast that we saw
or celebrity oh Ben Affleck
because the Press tour would be amazing
and he'll he's just like cocoon he'll
never get older and he'll never die
um let me see who would I who would I
pick but I can't know them oh wow [__]
when you say we can't know him like do
you mean biblically like we didn't [__]
them or because I would pick Christian
man Christian's like so knowledgeable
and [__]
somebody I don't personally know
Banff oh [__]
saved by the bank I'll save you guys
some dead air
um to replace me on the show
I would choose the little girl from
Ghostbusters afterlife Mckenna Grace
because she seems so nerdy and that she
would take the show technically to the
next level
and she's
an actress who plays it I don't know her
to me they're one in the same
so
she's also funny she like tells bad dad
jokes and like I like that
fair enough look at that a good answer
um thanks for stalling but I didn't
think of anything yet all right I got
one oh thank God uh
Caleb McLaughlin
the the black kid from stranger things
that is his last name right
um I think he's a nerd I think he's he's
deep in this particular scene
um I don't know if he podcasts or not
but clearly he knows how to use his
voice uh can put on a show and uh
yeah I mean it was either going to be
him or it's going to be Alana Pierce
no sorry
because I know you now you [__] it up
that's the monkey's paw of asking that
question
Markel so we can't do this now
[__]
so somebody I don't know no
who wants to do it
Isaac
Isaac is here on his birthday you came
from where Indiana
and it's Isaac's birthday give it up for
Isaac
[Music]
Isaac brought his wife and his like this
is even more impressive three [__]
children of a young age four
you left one at the hotel [__] man you
got that's like heirs and spares right
there
um so he brought three of them to see
Flash Gordon and left I guess the
smallest one at the hotel wash Joyce
um
uh drove 15 hours with four small
children in a car
19 and a half hours with [__] four
kids going where are we going again
you're like to the shittiest movie
theater on the planet
seats from the 80s
oh excellent point yeah you're such a
guy who wrote that [__] line
um
let me see uh yeah I'm [__] picking
Isaac but while we're on the subject
yeah well done Isaac
um uh while we're on the subject though
of people who drove distances uh
whenever we do fat man beyond back at
the scum and villainy cantina I don't
even know if Banff man knows this
um you know right directly in front of
us that's where the camera is there's a
booth where people always sit and Jamie
and Shannon have been there like you
know in the beginning I used to call cat
ears because she wore these [__]
headphones that had cat ears on them and
[__] but they've been to like almost
every live fat man beyond that we ever
did at uh this coming villainy Cantina
and last night when we were doing
Streets of Fire like we saw them in the
audience and they're here tonight where
are you kids sitting right now bam right
there what's the name of the podcast you
guys do
married with television oh [__] I should
oh I can't pick you because I know you
guys it's still you Isaac
uh but they came out from uh Los Angeles
to be here from Hollywood to actually be
here and stuff who can't yeah give it up
for a man
uh who came uh from Far let's let's do
this how many people have had show of
hands are from like you know the
tri-state area put your hands together
thank you for coming man we're not
discounting you at all but who came far
like Indiana and Los Angeles where'd you
come from
Anchorage Alaska [__]
oh my God this is so weird to see that
we have Night end day here as well
were you in the area for something else
you did not just come for this did you
he grew up in Delaware but he's been
living in Alaska since 2010. what
brought you to Alaska arguably the
[__] Delaware of the North
Air Force brought you out thank you for
your service give it up for him
wow Alaska
uh all right another more hands where
yes right there
no no no sit the [__] down not the
question
we're asking where you came from man
we're at that part of the show from
where
of course yeah we're looking for the
frequent flyer winners here yeah who's
go ahead Austin Texas man is and you
came in Just For This
[__] hey
um you were holding up [__] signs do
you still have your your signs so uh
what's your name again
Josh Josh came in from Austin Josh uh on
the that Kevin Smith Club on uh when I
was doing for a red hot minute
um the amp show uh last month and
whatnot I was talking about oh we're
doing uh the Muppet movie and he was
like I'm gonna if I could smoke with you
all [__] come out from Austin and I
was like yeah come on and he came and I
wasn't here
um so it it came bit the bullet and came
[__] again and beautifully you're
wearing a bathrobe right [__] love
that man like way to be comfy and [__] I
love that but he was holding up signs
like we were doing Let's Make a Deal
hold up one of your signs they can't you
bring it up here so everyone could see
it man but I walked up to the theater
today and he was outside and I thought
it was you
because he's got like the baseball cap
in the bathrobe I was like Kim's just
hanging out in front of his theater
that's weird I have been known to do
that
give it up for Josh everybody
okay show us your signs this one says it
may only be a chode but I'll still
swallow Kevin Smith's load
did you go all like that sweet
for or for amazing oral dictation call
me that's [__] hot
this guy loves the [__] smoker very nice
there's a there it is give it up your
job well done captain
first time anyone's ever did not have
done that like I've never been to any of
my shows let alone [__] fat man
beyond or where somebody like [__]
Let's Make a Deal that man like
the last few shows I've done he said we
both are just me uh he said I've seen
kind of sad which what the [__] man like
but because of that you were like let's
cheer him the [__] up
I've spent decades making my friends and
family uh and fans laugh and and is that
what it was I gotta communicate it to
the homeowner
and you actually respect you
and he figured it was a time for fans or
people to care about me to reciprocate
that's beautiful man thank you yes I
have uh
I have gone through a [__] thing
recently and stuff and I'll talk about
it somewhere down the road but that
means the world man um he was talking
about that at Flash Gordon screening
afterwards and I gave him a big hug I
appreciate that thank you for making the
trip from Austin
oh stop it
means the world
um okay uh hands where else of people
from far away oh okay you're like no I'm
not that I got a question questions
we'll get back to uh distance anybody
else hand in the air who can beat Alaska
you came from North Carolina that's
still a [__] distance you cross state
lines yeah
yes
the play no
the word wait you didn't come from
Greece just for the show
I lived there that came home I live in
Marlboro
how long were you living in Greece every
year three years in Greece what were you
doing there
military thank you for your service man
wow um how do you compare Greece to
Atlantic Highlands New Jersey just as
like [__] epic right
right on we are that's right tonight is
the grease of [__] New Jersey this is
Atlantic Highlands parthenium
how do you pronounce it
learning all sorts of [__] tonight uh
hands any place else uh from uh further
away or far away
all the way in the back what you got
Houston Texas oh my God you wrote in
with John did you fly or drive Josh you
flew did you guys fly or drive
and did you fly to do other things here
or just to do this
to get engaged oh [__]
[__] you came here for that yeah
yeah New Jersey is a state of Love why
why didn't you get engaged in Houston
was it what Drew you to the East Coast
he'd never been to the east coast before
just communicating it back go ahead
they went to Shenandoah National Park
where is that
in Virginia which is for Lovers yeah oh
oh [__] now we're seeing the
connection so while you were there
somebody popped the question
yeah so was it was it the mail popping
the question to the female I don't want
to assume that
it was this not unfortunately and it
went well you both seem like your
chipper
that's a long way to go for a no
what
uh surprised
been together 10 years
yeah oh God no I'm sure they want to get
married in front of relatives and [__]
like that
um 10 years what [__] took you so
long no uh well done man [__] until
when all and did you do it in Shenandoah
oh goodnight look at that man that's
awesome give it up for him what a great
story
what's your name for the home audience
like we don't want to [__] say
Gordon and Elaine well done Gordon and
Elaine
marriage is a well it's an institution
uh what do you got bamf man uh somebody
in chat earlier was from Gibraltar
like the Rock of Gibraltar yeah it's
company
so I thought that was kind of cool I
thought only like penguins live there or
something like birds I didn't know
people did but
uh right on but technically not here so
yeah well they're virtually here there
there is much there as I am
oh my God you're running yeah
welcome person from Gibraltar I'll uh I
want to give a shout out also to
somebody else who's there who when we
started doing this virtually during the
pandemic was
uh popped up in our chat room
and when gosh 20 years ago
this summer I he had quit Midtown Comics
and I took his job it was my first job
out of college and that's six Stone City
in New York yeah and six doe he and I
reconnected tonight's the first time
I've seen him because I see the back of
his head in your camera shot right there
so he's been we we've become friends
again 20 years later through through the
show on chat every week so what's your
name
Sixto and what and where did you come
from again originally Dominica and so
wait you took JC's job or vice versa so
you have the job and then JC took it
over and he passed like ships in the
night and then re-met online
yeah like 20 years later oh crazy
do you know what happens next you have
to go to Shenandoah together
one of you got to pop the question oh
that's adorable man
he said thanks JC
okay bye
uh that's all I got
aye
bye
Bamford question yes we'll get to uh
this question number three
yes and you know we'll do instead of the
normal food yeah we'll keep going all
right
that lady who likes Willa what's your
name
Laura give it up for Laura Laura's next
[Applause]
Laura what can we do you for oh
first of all happy Saint Patrick's Day
um so remains a two-parter question
um firstly as I was listening
lovely little candles uh I realized that
I would be so perfectly happy if you
would narrate the film of my life
so my first part of my question is who
would you want to narrate the film of
your life and then the second part is
what fiction author would you want to
write the story
give it up work
who would I want to narrate could it be
anybody living or dead
she's my father because he'd be alive
again
uh no the narrator of my life I would
have loved to have been Stan Lee that
would be amazing hey spider friends this
is Stanley here's what Kevin did today
masturbated furiously
look at him go he's so productive
Excelsior
um and what Creator would I like to
write my life
um oh hands down Neil Gaiman he's so
[__] inventive and so creative yeah
and he would take a boring life and make
it [__] interesting
there's my choices you
[Music]
um
I think
I mean it's it's sad because it won't
happen anymore I mean it's nothing he's
passed away but he seems to have
rescinded and and pulled back from some
performance in public life uh but James
Earl Jones
um I feel like would be
just that [__] yeah
everything would be so dire Mark
masturbated
excellent choice amazing
um and so who writes it uh my favorite
part of James Earl Jones narrating your
life would be his moment in Star Wars
where Han Solo shows up and he goes what
so whenever you did something weird
you'd be like what
like they're very excited James Earl
Jones yes my favorite Darth Vader moment
of all time and that even includes
[__] Rogue one where he [__] goes
total [__] surprised he never did it
again like Darth Vader is always [__]
chill and [__] but that one most what
it's not like my mother yes I find your
lack of Big Macs disturbing
uh and I think I I know it's it's a
little easy for me but I feel like Aaron
Sorkin would be the guy I would want to
hire for that oh my God you'd be so
[__] well written yeah right I get
all these [__] cool ass speeches and
we'd be walking up and down places and
[__] lots of walking and talking
with James Earl Jones is the voice of
God behind me
you seem to have forgotten something in
his bedroom
he walks back at each fourth and Sorkin
does more walking than those [__]
Lord of the Rings movies
uh what about you bamf man you got any
ideas
Banff
um just because I think it'd be silly
like Matthew McConaughey to do both
no [__] all right all right all right
both
wow
can he write yeah I mean or you just
want your life to be written on a bongo
beat we'll find out I mean he might run
to be governor of Texas I hope so
you think he's going to be governor of
Texas he keeps saying no but I think
he'll say yes eventually
I feel like if he's gonna write you a
life story you have to have way more
hacky sacks in your life
in order for that to be a thing he's
interested in
um all right that was question three man
now we're heading out to question the uh
normally we never go this [__] bonus
round yeah we're going further than
we've ever gone on this episode is that
a little girl over there with a question
oh boy
come on up
what's your name
oh my God you are a little girl like and
we've been cursing our full heads off
all night
give it up for Aaron everybody
[Applause]
my dad has been watching you for a long
time and he told me that
um you know the Avengers so I just
wanted to ask how do you know them
give it up for Aaron everybody
uh do I know the Avengers
here I'll give you all my I mean I know
their names
and I have met uh some of them
um I met uh Chris Evans
uh that's his name yeah I always you
know it's okay there's two of them I
know yeah yeah totally um met him when I
was on an episode of The Tonight Show
the Jay Leno tonight show and I was he
was the first guest I was the second
guest and I forget what he was there
promoting it wasn't Captain America but
he was there one he was there he was
working on or about to work on Captain
America too and seeing us sit next to
each other like on the [__] couch in
the chair we look like the number 10 at
that point he was very thin and I was
kind of round and [__] and I remember
during the break like there's a picture
of me where I'm like all thumbs up and
smiles and [__] and so when during the
break I wanted to talk about Marvel and
[__] and I was like oh my God what's it
like working for Marvel and he was like
it sucks
and he was really kind of down on it and
[__] but he was like well I don't know
this next one might be better and you
know of course the next one was way
better
um Robert Downey Jr I've only met once
and it was backstage at the San Diego
Comic-Con
um me and Jason Muse were downstairs in
the warehouse area uh having smokes we
were smoking cigarettes and stuff I was
big cigarette smoker back in the days
don't ever do that Aaron
um it's my PSA for the evening so we're
down there having a cigarette and the
elevator uh the freight elevator is how
they bring everybody up to do the hall h
and then come down and this was uh them
I think getting ready to promote uh Iron
Man 2 I think that's what they were
there for so the freight elevator comes
down and favs comes out and I know Fabs
and [__] so he nodded at me and I nodded
at him uh Gwyneth was on the on the
elevator as well and I knew her for like
a red hot minute years ago when she used
to date Ben Affleck she's a voice in the
clerk's cartoon she plays herself she
did not nod at me at all and uh and then
Robert Downey Jr was also on the
elevator and so when favs gave me the
nod and I nodded back Robert Downey Jr
looked over and then smoked right over
to us and I don't mean smoke like he
[__] rushed over he didn't run but he
walked very briskly shook my hands so
vigorously and he was like it is
excellent to meet you I I still hold
that in my heart like one day when I'm
dying as hopefully in a very old man and
[__] I'll be like I meant Iron Man you
know [__]
still [__] means the most to me um
have I I interviewed Hawkeye Jeremy
Renner
um and it was for the movie that he did
with
um Elizabeth Olsen which was a Wind
River something I think it was that it
was that Sundance and she was also an
Avenger so I can bring her up Elizabeth
Olsen was like so incredibly happy to
meet me but she was like oh my God we
used to watch me and my brother used to
watch does she have a brother I don't
know
I know she got those sisters and [__]
you can't [__] avoid them but wait
did he pass did you say he died
what Quicksilver
oh that was [__] good man bam she she
has a brother named Trent
thank you so there was a brother I'm
remembering correctly and she was like
me and my brother watched Mallrats all
the time when we were kids I'm a huge
fan she was so [__] enthusiastic and
and wonderful and Renner could not be
[__] bothered with me in the least I
was like Hey Hawkeye I was like uh-huh
can he go he talked to her pretty much
the whole time
um have I ever met uh Ruffalo
no I was a huge fan of You Can Count On
Me
I'm Tom Holland I I think I've met yeah
I did meet Tom Holland because I did a
um I think I don't know if it was the
Emerald City Comic Con or something like
that but it was one of the Comic Cons
where him and Anthony Mackey were guests
and so was Elizabeth Olsen and um Paul
Bettany as well so I was the guy they
chose to interview them on stage and uh
Tom was absolutely sweet but I think he
was way too young to know my [__] at all
or or way too classy
um he was very nice very very nice
um let me see Paul Bettany I sat next to
on an episode of The Talking Dead and uh
I'll never forget this because like you
know there's Mark talks about like the
fake laughter when you're reviewing like
famous people or whatever
um on that episode oh my God on that
episode we were talking about
um an episode of The Walking Dead that
is just played that went incredibly hard
it was just like Relentless like a thing
happened and another thing happened
another thing happened and I remember
going like you know they came to me and
Hardwick was like what'd you think of
the episode and I was like man watching
that episode was like how do I put this
because it was on TV I was like you know
how like when you're getting oral with
somebody and
dad will explain that right and um
I was like and you're done but they keep
going and stuff and you're like whoa
whoa whoa I was like it was exactly like
that it's like when you're tickled a lot
and you're done being tickled but
somebody keeps tickling you yes that's
that there you go well done
you're such a better dad than I ever was
um he laughed so legitimately hardcore
it wasn't a fake Hollywood I think you
could find the clip online and stuff he
was like he thought that was hysterical
so much so that when I saw him again at
that Comic-Con he's like you know what I
still find funny and he brought that
[__] up
um okay and then I've never have I met
Scarlett Johansson no I don't think so
um who
bam fams I [__] met he was in Jay and
Silent Bob reboot man
um he had uh done an interview at some
place at Vanity Fair or something where
he talked about the show he talked about
a fat man I think an Incarnation would
it might have been Fat Man on Batman at
that point I don't know if it was fat
man beyond you but he talked about how
like uh him and taika waititi like
changed [__] up on Thor Ragnarok he's
like we listened to like Kevin Smith on
a podcast talking about like why won't
they do something different or something
like that I was like [__] on on Thor
too and uh rather than be like [__]
Kevin Smith they were like yeah let's
[__] do something different let's do
something more fun so he gave me like
partial credit or something like that
and when we were casting reboot I was
like oh my God somebody reach out to
Hemsworth and see if he'll come do a
thing and he [__] said yeah and he
came and showed up and it was we were in
post on the movie and the piece that we
shot was him as a hologram um and he was
promoting end game he was out in Los
Angeles for the premiere of end game and
so he came to us on a day where he was
like he had just done the Ellen show he
did another show and he was doing the
end game Premiere in Los Angeles then he
was getting on a plane with the rest of
the Avengers and they were going I think
to London to do the premiere there and
he built an hour and a half block into
his schedule to come shoot with us and
like I'll never forget because Liz
Destro is one of the producers on the
movie and so she was like showing him in
to a room and uh where he was gonna get
changed to go do his things he was
wearing something else he wanted to wear
something in the flick and she was like
she was talking to he was like is this a
room okay to change in and she was like
oh absolutely and he [__] ripped his
shirt off right there in front of her
and Liz is like a no-nonsense nuts and
bolt producer but she was like I got so
hard
um
so while he was there we shot with him
he was absolutely lovely he was another
guy that was like I'm a huge fan going
way back and and of the movies I made
when I was younger and stuff and then um
he was like are you going to the end
game Premiere tonight and I was like oh
man I don't know any Avengers and he
goes you do now and he invited me to be
his guest and so I got to go to the
premiere with Harley as a guest of
Hemsworth and we sat in his row with the
other [__] Avengers and [__] like
that and um it was weird normally when
you go to like premieres the industry
premieres they're very dry there's not
like a lot of enthusiasm and stuff but
end game being what it was
everyone was like going crazy in the
audience even though a lot of people
worked on it but I was like the loudest
person like everything that happened I
was like gosh and my kid was so
embarrassed but I remember at one point
like Hemsworth looks over at me and goes
uh so I've I've met him and um I guess
is that all the Avengers my my favorite
part of that story Batman is that uh if
you know this podcast at all then you
know that Kevin historically is not a
dude to be like that movie sucked
so this is the life of being the dude
sitting next to Kevin like you know the
unnamed black dude on the plane that
goes down and also
so it was like clearly I'm the dude who
hated Thor the Dark World but we saw
Kevin he didn't like the movie so we
decided to change it up a little bit I
got the credit for you you got the
credit for me [__] on their movie
um but yeah it'll be wow this is playing
out of Anchorage Alaska Kevin Smith died
also a black dude
laughs
who played a lot of video games yeah
um my the other my only other tangential
connection uh to The Avengers uh other
than of course working with Stan Lee and
stuff
um who had a thing or two to do with
those characters
um is uh it growman's Chinese Theater
out in Hollywood uh where you know
there's in Hollywood they got the Walk
of Fame where people got stars on the
sidewalk with their names on it and [__]
and that's a high honor I've never
received yet I'm still alive so it may
happen in my lifetime but an even higher
honor is uh there's a small courtyard in
front of groman's Chinese Theater where
stars have been putting their handprints
and Footprints like going back to the
40s and maybe even earlier than that and
um Jason Muse and I uh were lucky enough
to get chosen to put our hands and feet
prints in the cement at groman's Chinese
Theater which meant the world to me
because when I was I've known about this
place since I was a kid when I was a kid
we went to California uh because my
father was like we got to go on a
vacation and the fat one likes movies
let's [__] go there and stuff so he
took me my brother and sister my mom uh
to uh Los Angeles and to Hollywood and
one of the first places we went was to
the grumman's Chinese Theater Courtyard
and uh you know my father was he knew I
loved movies and stuff so he was like
showing me the handprints and Footprints
going like this is this person he's like
this is Jimmy Durante he put his nose
into the cement this is Marilyn Monroe
for the older people I was only
interested in seeing the footprints of
uh just recently Darth Vader R2D2 and
C-3PO had put their Footprints into the
cement there's a picture online of me
and my brother in the most 70s [__]
outfits you've ever seen kneeling in
front of those Footprints and my father
right before we left I'm sorry I told
the story to death so people have heard
it before but you're young and you
probably haven't
um right before we left my father was
just like he said a thing that a father
says to a kid or an adult says to a kid
like feel like baseball it's like maybe
you'll be in the major leagues one day
before we left uh Roman's Chinese
Theater that day my father was after we
looked at all and cased every footprint
in every handprint my father was like
maybe you'll be here one day and 40
years later I got to do the same thing
and put I took my father's ashes with me
he's dead and I took his urn and pushed
it into the cement so right next to my
footprints in my handprints is my
father's urn as well there's a circle
and people like what's that Circle I was
like that's my dead father and they're
like he sure was small
um
but I tell you all of this to say this
me and Jay are right below the Avengers
like all the Avengers did their
handprints and Footprints as well so you
could see the entire Avengers Clan and
like right below us there's me and Jay
so I I yeah I guess I have kind of
interacted with with all the Avengers
your dad's right I was sitting there
going like his dad this guy this poor
kid got lied to but you're right I have
met a lot of a lot of the Avengers
excellent question give it a pair
uh I've never met any Avengers I I have
like a couple of Avengers adjacent
encounters like I my favorite is I was a
Comic-Con I want to say it was like
2018 maybe maybe 2017. and I was
crossing if you know anything about
Comic-Con there's 150 000 people who
descend on like 12 square blocks of San
Diego so it is the most densely occupied
um 12 blocks in the country at that time
yeah and so I'm crossing the street to
go from the Gaslamp district which is
the part of San Diego across these like
train tracks and this whole thing to get
to the actual convention center and it
becomes this like sea of humanity all
trying to get across these train tracks
and so I'm standing there with my friend
he's an actor his name is on a good
fight he was on Mike and Molly sweet guy
and we're just stand there walking
across and then there's this woman
dressed as a pink Power Ranger
having the best time I've ever seen
somebody have a Comic-Con like she's
just like dancing around and kind of
spinning on poles and like dude like
interpretive dances the pink Power
Ranger I was like how come I can't have
that kind of fun when I come to Comic
I'll never be that happy what am I doing
wrong like this is my 15th time I should
be having a better time but she was
having the time of her life and it was
only like a couple days later when I got
back to LA did I learn that I discover
and I was like talking to her and she
would like say no this is my first time
here I'm having so much fun this is
great like Wonder coming costume because
I always heard about it but never did it
that was Lupita Nyong'o
who was there for the Black Panther the
big like we're making a Black Panther
movie look at our first trailer and
that's how she did the con as the pink
Power Ranger and I've never seen
somebody so excited to be anywhere as
she was excited to be in San Diego and
just getting to like frolic
um and then I met Benedict Wong at a at
a comic convention in the UK when we did
the the London show where we did fat man
beyond yeah we're Fat Man on Batman at
that point and uh and he was just in the
green room just chilling out and so I
walk over and I was talking to somebody
I don't remember and he sat down and
said hi I'm Benny
no you're not you're Wong
foreign
for a couple minutes and he just passed
on but I a man got Superstar struck when
John Cleese showed up oh [__] like and I
think Benedict Cumberbatch was also
there I didn't get to meet him but I got
to watch him lose his marbles when John
Cleese came in and and he's like should
I go talk to him I don't know should I
go talk to him I'm not sure
and he finally worked up the stones to
go tell John Cleese how much he meant to
him and that was the other object listen
of everybody's a fan of something yeah
it doesn't matter at what point in the
pecking order at what level of the
hierarchy you are you grew up loving a
thing everybody did and sometimes your
life will lead you to a place where you
get to confront that for real and tell
somebody what you what they meant to you
and like never miss those opportunities
because they've only ever come by once
if you're lucky
pretty cool Kev is you just
complimenting me
okay
who told you to
oh nice job buddy well done
um that's beautiful yeah it was lovely
um one more uh Avengers Jason story in
arguably the leader of the Avengers I
would say is Kevin Kevin foggy roblesu
uh the guy over at Marvel Studios who's
like The Mastermind beyond all the
interconnected movies that we love so
much and um years ago five years ago I
had a massive heart attack you probably
didn't hear about it I'd never talk
about it
and uh lived through it and [__] and one
day like maybe two weeks after I
survived it I was driving on uh
Mulholland Drive in Los Angeles I was
heading to the valley and my phone rang
and I didn't recognize the number but
I'd answered it and I was like hello and
they were like hold for Kevin foggy and
I was like oh my God like Kevin feige
like of course and so he got on the horn
and he goes Kevin this is Kevin I was a
Kevin this is Kevin like you know we did
that for 20 minutes and uh
and he was like uh I'd heard about your
heart attack and like I just wanted to
reach out and say I'm so glad you're
alive
um as a fellow Kevin from New Jersey
because he's also from New Jersey who
dreamed of being involved in movies like
you making clerks and and getting into
the movie business was hugely
inspirational for me so as he's saying
this I'm getting like all choked up but
then also I'm like wait a second like
because I survived a heart attack Kevin
feige is gonna offer me a Marvel movie
right now
and so there I am sitting there going
waiting for it and I was like well
thanks Kev that means the world man he
goes I just wanted to tell you that bye
and he hung up and [__]
um okay one last question uh yes time
for our fifth pick oh I get to pick of
course oh geez trying to see what I can
see what can I see
oh yeah you I see don't worry about you
um let's go all the way in the back on
the aisle
yeah you
what's your name
Renny give it up for Renny everybody
[Applause]
so with this being the end of The Ides
of Mark I wanted to know what the best
thing the funniest thing and the most
inspirational takeaway that you've had
from from all this
the best thing the funniest thing and
the most inspirational thing
um
I mean for me I two of these movies I've
never seen on the big screen before and
so I'd never seen Dune on the big screen
I had never seen Streets of Fire those
were those are home video discoveries
for me
um Flash Gordon I had gotten to see as I
told the people who were here it was it
was very
um seminal of a movie for me in that
it's the movie where I discovered that
people make movies because up until that
point I just thought movies existed I
didn't know that they had to be conjured
into reality by Craftsmen and writers
and directors and actors and stuff I
just thought that Prince Baron was
Prince Baron I didn't know that that was
an actor playing him
um and so the the best part of that for
me was just kind of a seeing stuff that
I'd never seen bigger than I'd ever seen
them wait did you tell the dad's story
here because it's so beautiful
um I might have said it before in the
podcast I definitely said it to the
people who are for Flash Gordon but
when I was nine I saw Flash Gordon in
the movie theater because my dad took me
as a Star Wars fan to everything that
had spaceships or laser beams or
whatever because the boy likes space
we'll take him to the space stuff and uh
and so I'm sitting next to him in Flash
Gordon which not a great movie for
children
um there's all kinds of weird sexual
Dynamics and incest and yeah it's all
that stuff but I'm sitting there at the
scene where flash uh if you're familiar
with the movie at all he's sticking his
hand into a giant tree stump which has
some kind of Scorpion creature at the
center of it and and so your the tension
of that scene is is Flash Gordon about
to die and I at nine years old
completely expected him to die because I
didn't understand how movies worked yet
and so my dad leans over sees me on the
verge of tears and says don't worry they
never kill the hero and so I stopped
working and Flash Gordon didn't die and
whatever he marries Dale Arden I suppose
but that was the first time that I had
encountered the phrase they never killed
a hero
who's they who are the they you're
talking about and that sort of led me to
start paying attention to movie credits
that led me to start paying attention to
like reading magazines like starlog and
cinephen testique and fangoria and
discovering that it was a job that
people had to make these movies and
that's when I discovered that maybe
that's a job that I could have at some
point so to watch Flash Gordon and to be
reminded of my dad who isn't dead he's
just not here
um he's in Hempstead
um but uh
but to be reminded of that moment it was
such a sweet story when I thought your
dad was dead
now I'm going to see him tomorrow for
dinner
um
but you're so lucky
yeah come on Kev uh but no it's and so
to just to live in that moment again
when the World opened up to me and the
future became a path that I could follow
is what this is why Flash Gordon means
as much as it does to me
um so getting to see that was I think
the best thing the funniest thing
um was most of Dune is hilarious
uh because it's it's just the bunkerest
of Bonker movies but
um yeah every every I I had never
noticed before how many things are
happening in the background of that
movie that are insane that I just never
saw so there's a sequence early on where
a guild Navigator I don't know what you
guys know about Dune you shouldn't know
that much about Dune it's not that great
a movie I still love it but anyway this
giant creature uh whose face uh is head
is shaped like a like balls and his
mouth is like a vagina and he smokes a
lot of spice weed Aaron asked Dad what
those things are I was very careful to
use the appropriate technology I mean
terminology
um and so and he's like in this giant
like aquarium thing and he gets ushered
out and it's as you've seen and there's
this one dude in the corner who's just
vacuuming up like he's just working the
floor he's like you know the guy who's
working the Zamboni I guess in the
middle of stuff and he's just like doing
his gig and that I lost my poop at that
dude who like David Lynch was like you
vacuum everybody else just watch
okay director
um and then what was the last one the
most moving thing most inspirational
it's that all of these movies exist none
of them are great but everybody who made
them made them committed to having them
be movies that people could see and
they've all got some semblance of
quality in them like Streets of Fire is
not a wall-to-wall great movie but the
music is great you know some of the
performances are great Bill Paxton is
committed to being that kind of a kind
of Greaser douchebag
um but every movie has people who care
about making that movie and every every
one of these Craftsmen got up every day
at six o'clock in the morning to drive
to a set where some dude is polishing
the sets of Flash Gordon to be as shiny
as humanly possible when the dumbest
things possible happen on those sets
um and as a person who wants to make
movies and wants to make TV
that level of dedication to the
ridiculous is always inspirational to me
[Applause]
um look uh over the course of three days
we've done this like it was lovely to
see people come from far away from close
and stuff to see anybody show up to come
watch Dune with us was pretty cool and
stuff so that that was meaningful but
what are the three categories again it's
funniest
the best fine best moment funniest
moment inspiration most inspirational
um hands down I believe all three happen
tonight when I finally learned how to
pronounce Archie pelago
ladies and gentlemen if you had a good
time this evening
[Applause]
I'm gonna remind you uh if you're here
in the room or if you're home watching
uh tomorrow at Jane Sal and Bob so you
could stash Mark is going to be signing
I'll be there as well come down to the
stash get your stuff signed say hello in
person to Mr Mark Bernardin
um uh let me see uh don't forget there's
stuff coming up here at modcastle
Cinemas if you want to come out for it
and stuff uh the Impractical Jokers
movie a double feature on 420 uh looks
like 422 we're doing a Chasing Amy thing
uh tickets always available it's
mycastlecinemas.com
um and what other housekeeping do I have
um it means the world that this many
people came out on a Friday night
particularly Friday night when most
people in the world are like let's get
drunk uh on St Patrick's Day the fact
that you all came out to do the show uh
really turn my frown upside down I was
having a kind of shitty day and boy you
cats really spun it for me so thank you
for flipping the script uh and being
here means the absolute world
[Applause]
uh I want to thank everyone that made
this possible give it up for smartcastle
keeper Ernie O'Donnell
[Music]
uh our man up in the booth give it up
for Christian
our man on the other side of the country
give it up for Banff man JC
[Music]
uh but there is no fat man beyond uh
without the man that sits to my left and
there's certainly no odds of Mark
without him give it up for the great
Mark Bernard and everybody
and that kids is fat man beyond for this
week I'm Kevin Smith I'm Mark Bernard
tune in next time same fat Time same fat
channels podcast.com or youtube.com
Kevin Smith Jeff's kiss everybody good
night
[Applause]
[Music]
this
welcome to the AKA ask Kevin every Saga
has a 10-year anniversary ladies and
gentlemen and this is what happens with
Jay and Silent Bob get old off Kevin
Smith
[Music]